I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone. Hello. Welcome to another revisited deep dive episode of Office, ladies. Yes, you guys, you heard my lady friend. Today we are going back over the first half of season three of Office, ladies podcast. We're going to respond to your questions, your comments about all the things we missed. We might not get to all of them guys, but
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好。你好。欢迎收看另一期《办公室女士》的回顾深度解析节目。是的，伙计们，你们听到我的女性朋友说的了。今天我们将回顾《办公室女士》播客第三季的前半部分。我们将回答你们的问题、你们对所有我们漏掉的细节的评论。伙计们，我们可能无法回答所有问题，但是
we're going to try. So that's basically everything from gay witch hunt to benihana Christmas. Yes. Now, Angela, we're calling it a revisited deep dive. We did one of these with Ken Kuapas, where we really focused on casino night only. You know, like you said, we're going to do multiple episodes today. We had some people write in with ideas for what we could call these. I love it. I love it. What, what? So some people thought we could call it a remix. Some people thought we could call it a rerun. But Joel and Emma wrote in and said, we should call these episodes second drinks. Oh, that is perfect. I love it. That is so good. Second drink. So we are going to do a second drink of gay witch hunt
我们会尽力。所以这基本上涵盖了从《同性恋搜捕》到《班尼哈那圣诞节》的所有内容。是的。现在，安吉拉，我们称之为回顾深度解析。我们曾和肯·夸帕斯一起做过一次，当时我们只专注于《赌场之夜》。你知道的，就像你说的，我们今天会做多期节目。有人写信给我们，提出了关于这些节目叫什么名字的想法。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。什么，什么？所以有人认为我们可以叫它“混音”。有人认为我们可以叫它“重播”。但是乔尔和艾玛写信说，我们应该把这些节目叫做“第二杯”。哦，这太完美了。我太喜欢了。这真是太棒了。第二杯。所以我们要为《同性恋搜捕》做一杯“第二杯”
all the way to benihana Christmas, but we're also going to do a deep dive interview with our editor of nine years, Dave Rogers. Yes. And Angela, I want you to listen to this sweet note that we got about Dave from Angela Newman. Okay. She wrote in, she said, I got to meet Dave Rogers. Once the office was done filming, I went and waited outside the gates in hopes that someone would come out and let me go in and see the set. Sure enough, after a few hours, Dave came out and was beyond generous, gave me a full tour of the office and warehouse. It was the best day ever. Oh my gosh. Well, that is just the Dave that we know, Jenna. He is just so lovely like that. Yes. Well, we're really excited to talk to him. You
一直到《班尼哈那圣诞节》，但我们还将与合作了九年的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯进行深度专访。是的。安吉拉，我想让你听听我们从安吉拉·纽曼那里收到的关于戴夫的温馨便条。好的。她写道，我曾有幸见到戴夫·罗杰斯。一旦《办公室》拍完，我就去大门外等着，希望有人能出来让我进去参观片场。果不其然，几个小时后，戴夫出来了，而且极其慷慨，带我完整参观了办公室和仓库。那是有生以来最棒的一天。哦天哪。嗯，这正是我们认识的戴夫，珍娜。他就是那样温和可爱。是的。好吧，我们非常高兴能和他聊天。你们
guys, no one knows the show like Dave. Truly. He like watched us and edited us for nine years. The guy knows every detail about the show and we're super, super excited. Yes. And you guys sent in a bunch of questions. Thank you for sending those in. Angela, I'd like to start this revisit second drink by addressing what is possibly my, I know what it is, biggest faux pas so far in this podcast. I just, I want to get it over with. Do it. Okay. I am calling this. This really made me laugh, by the way. All the comments really cracked me up. So you guys, thank you. I am calling this revisited fast fact number one. I'm going to really shit the bed on the plot of Locuz talking. I got it like totally wrong.
伙计们，没有人比戴夫更了解这部剧了。真的。他看了我们九年，也给我们剪辑了九年。这家伙知道关于这部剧的每一个细节，我们真的非常非常兴奋。是的。你们也发来了很多问题。谢谢你们发来这些。安吉拉，我想通过指出这可能是我的——我知道是什么——我在这个播客中迄今为止最大的失误，来开始这次“第二杯”回顾。我只是想把它了结。做吧。好的。我称之为。顺便说一句，这真的把我逗笑了。所有的评论真的让我笑喷了。所以伙计们，谢谢你们。我称之为回顾快讯第一期。我在《看谁在说话》的剧情上真的搞砸了。我完全搞错了。
Well, and I was no help because I haven't seen it. So I was like, oh no way. You guys remember at the beginning of the merger, Michael is pretending to do a bit based on Locuz talking, this movie. And I very confidently, very confidently did this whole explanation of the plot. So many of you wrote in, I mean too many to name. Truly a lot. There were a lot. But Sarah Elliott, Liano Brian, Rebecca Gernet, Katie Humphries and Melissa all said, Jenna, John Travolta is not the father of the talking Bruce Willis baby. It's actually Kirstie Alley's boss. And yeah, I mean, yes, it all came back to me once I sent this message. They didn't have a one night stand. He wasn't the dad. No, he got her to the hospital and
好吧，我一点也帮不上忙，因为我没看过。所以我当时想，哦，不会吧。你们还记得在合并开始时，迈克尔假装在做一个基于电影《看谁在说话》的段子吗？我非常自信地，非常自信地对剧情做了解释。你们很多人写信来，我是说多得无法列举。真的有很多。确实有很多。但是莎士·埃利奥特、莉亚诺·布莱恩、丽贝卡·格内特、凯蒂·汉弗莱斯和梅丽莎都说，珍娜，约翰·特拉沃尔塔不是那个会说话的布鲁斯·威利斯宝宝的父亲。其实是克尔茜·艾利的老板。是的，我的意思是，是的，当我发出这条信息时，这一切都回想起来了。他们没有过一夜情。他不是爸爸。不，他把她送到医院，然后
then just somehow hung around. Well, I'm afraid now I'm afraid because I don't get it wrong again. But somehow I believe he goes in the hospital with her. I don't I should check. Lady, this is such a drink. You got to follow up. Here's the thing. I think clearly you and I were meant to watch this together. Even if we have to do it over zoom, I will bring the rose for myself, I guess over zoom. And you and I are going to watch this movie together. It's a BFF date. Oh, lady, I'm so excited for it. We will watch. Look who's talking together. And we will bring you our discoveries. Yes, I love it. Okay, well, Jenna, if that was your revisited fast fact number one, are you ready for my fast fact number two? Yes.
然后不知怎么的就留下来了。好吧，我现在有点害怕，因为我怕又弄错了。但不知何故，我坚信他陪她进了医院。我不知道——我应该查一下。女士，这真是一杯“第二杯”。你得跟进。事情是这样的，我觉得显然你和我注定要一起看这部电影。即使我们必须通过 Zoom 一起看，我想我也会在 Zoom 上为自己准备好玫瑰花。然后你和我将一起看这部电影。这是一次闺蜜约会。哦，女士，我太兴奋了。我们会看的。一起看《看谁在说话》。我们会带上我们的发现回来。是的，我太喜欢了。好吧，珍娜，如果那是你的回顾快讯第一期，你准备好迎接我的快讯第二期了吗？是的。
I said we'd never been on a boat before. Oh, of course, we've been on a boat. We've been on a big old honking boat. Those crews. Yeah, those crews, lady. I mean, we were on a boat for three days together. Yeah, we got the news that you were going to be a series regular while on a boat together while on a boat. Now, listen, it was docked for two days. We only went out out and about on it one day. I think Jenna in my brain, I thought of it as like work and not like recreational. You know, I think that's why it went in my brain like that. We've never been recreational boating. Yes, that's it. Exactly. That is absolutely true. And we will have to do that. You know, what would be amazing is if we could
我说过我们以前从未坐过船。哦，当然，我们坐过船。我们坐过一艘又大又吵的破船。那些剧组。是的，那些剧组，女士。我的意思是，我们一起在船上待了三天。是的，我们在船上时接到了你将成为固定演员的消息——在船上时。现在听着，它停泊了两天。我们只有一天出海兜风。珍娜，我想在我的脑海里，我把它当作工作，而不是休闲娱乐。你知道，我想这就是为什么它在我的脑海里是这样的。我们从来没有为了休闲划过船。是的，就是这样。完全正确。这绝对是真的。我们必须去体验一下。你知道，如果我们可以
go recreational boating while watching LaCouse talking, because then that would just check all the boxes. Well, then one of our husbands better be driving. Oh, dear. Oh, dear. Yes. Well, we have been on a boat lots and lots and lots of you wrote in to tell us and you were right. You were right. All right. Well, revisited fast fact number three is good news. This is not a mess up. This is a triumph. Oh, yes. And that triumph is heartbreak in the break room. Oh my gosh, you guys. We discussed Pam's hunchy posture, her sexy hand at sweater from her mom and her rejection by Jim in the break room scene of the merger. We thought it would make the perfect inspiration for a country
一边看《看谁在说话》，一边进行休闲划船，那就太棒了，因为那样就万事俱备了。那我们的丈夫中最好有一个人在开车。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。是的。好吧，我们坐过船，你们有成百上千的人写信告诉我们，你们是对的。你们是对的。好吧，回顾快讯第三期是个好消息。这不是一个失误。这是一个伟大的胜利。哦，是的。而这个胜利就是休息室里的心碎。哦天哪，伙计们。我们讨论了帕姆驼背的姿势、她妈妈织的性感手套毛衣，以及在合并场景的休息室里被吉姆拒绝。我们认为这会成为乡村音乐的完美灵感
song. We asked you guys to send in your songs and oh my God, holy waka moly. Did you ever take that call to action? It has been such a delight and joy for Jenna and I. There are so many. We haven't even made a dent. We haven't made a dent. And so we've been posting them on office ladies pod, you know, our Instagram. And I just want you guys to know side note. Um, I saw one time someone commented like, Oh, you know, maybe your team post these things. Uh, no team. It's just me and Jenna. Oh, yeah. There's no team behind our Instagram guys. It's us. We are a two lady show here. Um, so that's why sometimes. Well, we're not super active on it, guys, because, you know, we're moms and we're busy. And anyway, we are going to try to keep
歌曲。我们请大家发送你们的歌曲，天哪，我的天啊。你们真的响应了那个号召吗？这对珍娜和我来说是一件非常高兴和快乐的事。有太多了。我们甚至还没触及皮毛。我们还没触及皮毛。所以我们把它们发到了 office ladies pod，也就是我们的 Instagram 上。我只想让大家知道，顺便说一句。嗯，我看到有一次有人评论说，“哦，你知道，也许是你们的团队发这些东西的。”呃，没有团队。只有我和珍娜。哦，是的。我们的 Instagram 背后没有团队，伙计们。是我们。我们这里是一个只有两位女士的节目。嗯，这就是为什么有时。好吧，我们在上面不是很活跃，伙计们，因为，你知道，我们是妈妈，我们很忙。总之，我们打算尽量保持
posting these every week because they are just such a joy. And you guys, they have meant so much to us. Thank you. Well, lady, I have a surprise. What? Okay. You know, Rhett Miller from the old 97s is an old friend of mine. I do. And I'm, I'm like, really jealous. And it's just like, Jenna, I always think of you as like sort of the same level of dorkiness. But then every once in a while, you have this like, really cool friend. And I'm like, what the heck? You have way cool friends, Angela. I have one or two. But, but, but Rhett is definitely one of yours. He is. I, yes, I own it. He's one of my cool friends. Well, he sent in a version of Heartbreak in the Break Room. Yes. And you guys, it is fan flip and tastic. Sam, can you play the song?
每周发布这些内容，因为它们太令人高兴了。而且伙计们，它们对我们意义重大。谢谢。好吧，女士，我有个惊喜。什么？好吧，老97乐队的雷特·米勒是我的老朋友。我知道。而且我，我感觉——真的很嫉妒。就像，珍娜，我一直认为你和我是那种同样水平的怪胎。但每隔一段时间，你就会有这样一个真正酷的朋友，然后我就想，搞什么鬼？你有很多很酷的朋友，安吉拉。我有那么一两个。但是，但是，但是雷特绝对是你的朋友之一。他是。我，是的，我承认。他是我那些很酷的朋友之一。好吧，他寄来了一版《休息室里的心碎》。是的。伙计们，这真是太他妈棒了。山姆，你能放一下这首歌吗？
Heartbreak in the Break Room. Tears on your cheeks. This was not the reunion you'd been dreaming of for weeks. You heard the bell toll. You did not know. Heartbreak in the Break Room. Don't pull your heart out to the coffee machine. Discard your dreams in the recycling. You should have known better than to wear your sexier sweater. Heartbreak in the Break Room. Lump in your throat. Well, you floated it out there, but it didn't even float. The music was playing. The world set its tune. Heartbreak in the Break Room. Heartbreak in the Break Room. Heartbreak in the Break Room. Maybe that's why they call it a break room. Maybe that's why they call it a break room. Heartbreak in the Break Room. Tears on your cheeks. This was not the reunion you'd been dreaming of
休息室里的心碎。眼角挂着泪水。这不是你幻想了数周的重逢。你听到了丧钟敲响。你却一无所知。休息室里的心碎。不要把心掏给咖啡机。把你的梦想丢进回收站。你早该知道不该穿你那件更性感的毛衣。休息室里的心碎。如鲠在喉。好吧，你把它抛了出去，但它甚至都没有漂浮。音乐在播放。世界设定了它的曲调。休息室里的心碎。休息室里的心碎。休息室里的心碎。也许这就是为什么它们称之为休息室。也许这就是为什么它们称之为休息室。休息室里的心碎。眼角挂着泪水。这不是你幻想了数周的重逢。
for weeks. Well, you heard the bell toll. You did not know for who. Heartbreak in the Break Room. Heartbreak in the Break Room. I mean, we were rocking out in our perspective closets the whole time. That's so dang good. I love it so much. So, here's how I met Rhett. Rhett knew rain somehow and rain brought Rhett to set. Well, rain loves music. I feel like he's he's like a real active. Oh, yeah. Rain's a whole music guy. He knows all the cool music people. So, he brought Rhett to set and they wanted to make this funny video and rain pulled me aside and said, will you do this video in Michael's office with me and Rhett Miller? And I was like, what? I was like, wait, is it some guy named Rhett Miller or like Rhett Miller from the old 97s
好吧，你听到了丧钟响起，你不知道为谁而鸣。休息室里的心碎。休息室里的心碎。我的意思是，我们全程都在各自的壁橱里摇滚。太棒了。我太喜欢了。所以，我是这样认识雷特的。雷特不知怎么认识了雷恩，雷恩把雷特带到了片场。好吧，雷恩热爱音乐。我觉得他是个非常积极的——哦，是的。雷恩是个彻头彻尾的音乐迷。他认识所有酷炫的音乐人。所以他把雷特带到了片场，他们想拍一段有趣的视频，雷特把我拉到一边说，你愿意和我和雷特·米勒一起在迈克尔的办公室里拍这段视频吗？我当时想，什么？我心想，等等，是一个叫雷特·米勒的家伙，还是我超级崇拜的那个老97乐队的雷特·米勒？他说，就是那个。然后我想，太酷了。好吧，我表现得很酷。我会去和雷特一起在迈克尔的办公室拍这段视频。太有趣了。之后，雷特说，嘿，如果你想去听演唱会，随时告诉我，你可以来。好吧，李和他的哥哥泰勒是超级粉丝。所以我们都去了。这可以说是我们友谊的开始。伙计们，雷特真的是最好的人。后来我最终和弗莱德·阿米森一起为他的歌曲《上帝保佑》拍了一支音乐录影带。我太喜欢他了。而且，我也找到了我们在《办公室》片场拍的那段视频。是的。我们可以发布它吗？我们可以发布它吗？天哪。所以我们要这么做。我们会把他的歌发布在 Office Ladies pod 上。然后我们的快讯里，我会发布一个指向这个
that I'm a huge fan of? He was like, it's that one. And I was like, that's cool. Yeah, I'll play it cool. I'll go do this video with Rhett and Michael's office. It was so fun. And afterwards, Rhett said, hey, if you ever want to come to a concert, just let me know and you can come. Well, Lee and his brother Tyler are huge fans. So, we all went. And this kind of started our friendship. You guys, Rhett is literally the nicest guy. Then I ended up doing a music video for his song Good with God with Fred Armisen. I just love him. And also, I found that video that we made on the set of the office. Yes. Can we post it? Can we post it? Oh my gosh. So here's what we'll do. We will post his song and Office Ladies pod. And then in our stories, I'll post a link to this
YouTube 视频的链接。哦天哪。太棒了。我迫不及待想看看那个。女士，我觉得有一件事你和我从来没有谈过，那就是我猜我们俩都拍过音乐录影带。等等，什么？是的。我没有意识到。我的意思是，我依稀记得你拍过音乐录影带，但我不懂。我想我忘了。我在90年代拍过克莱·沃克的乡村音乐录影带。克莱·沃克。哦，有人知道吗？有人知道吗？我穿着那个。还记得工装靴吗？但就像女孩们穿的那样，配牛仔短裤。还有，一件上衣。我记得这个造型。是的。他在一个舞台上唱歌，但就像在一个牧场里。然后周围有一群人只是那种——我坐在那里跟着音乐拍大腿。我成了一个模糊的影子，一个转瞬即逝的小点。
YouTube video. Oh my God. Amazing. I cannot wait to see that. Lady, I feel like there's something you and I've never spoken about is that I guess we've both been in music videos. Wait, what? Yes. I didn't realize. I mean, I sort of remember you doing a music video, but I don't know. I guess I forgot. I in the 90s was in a country music video for Clay Walker. Clay Walker. Oh, anyone? Anyone? I wore that. Remember the construction boots, but like girls wore them with like jeans shorts. And like, like a top. I remember this look. Yeah. And he was like singing on a stage, but like on a ranch. And then there was a bunch of people around just kind of like, I was sitting kind of slapping my leg to the music. I'm like, I'm a blur. I'm a blip. It's
就像你几乎看不到我一样。你猜那首歌是什么？什么？非常朗朗上口。听起来有点像这样。如果我能靠爱你赚到一百万，我会在一两周内成为百万富翁。我会做我热爱的事，并热爱我所做的事，如果我能靠爱你赚到一百万。我喜欢这个。这是一首很棒的歌。是的，所以我们俩都拍过音乐录影带。我的意思是，你在音乐录影带里稍微更正规一些。我的意思是，我只是穿着工装靴跑龙套的。这也算数。这也算数。好吧，伙计们，你们可以在 Stage It 上一周看到雷特表演四天。那是 stage 和 IT，Stage It。他的 Twitter 上有相关信息 @雷特·米勒，R-H-E-T-T-M-I-L-L-E-R。你们可能还可以点播《休息室里的心碎》，雷特。
like you barely can see me. Guess what the song was? What? It's very catchy. It went a little something like this. If I could make a million out of loving you, I'd be a millionaire in a week or two. I'd be doing what I love and love and what I do if I can make a million out of loving you. I love this. This is a great song. Yes. So we were both in a music video. I mean, you're a little bit more legitimately in the music video. I mean, I was like an extra in my construction boots. It all counts. It all counts. All right. Well, you guys, you can see Rhett perform four days a week on Stage It. So that's stage and IT Stage It. And there's information on his Twitter at Rhett Miller, R-H-E-T-T-M-I-L-L-E-R. And you can probably request Heartbreak in the Break Room, Rhett.
哦，请点播吧。请点播它。还有，老97乐队刚刚发行了他们的新专辑《第12张》，其中包含歌曲《关掉电视》。你猜怎么着？说到音乐录影带。我也在里面客串了一个小角色。天哪，雷特。我觉得你的视频里可能还需要几个《办公室》女士。哦，我希望如此。我在家里拍的，然后把素材发了过去。真的很酷。你得找找我。我在其中一台电视上。就像一个小彩蛋，但我们爱你，雷特。非常感谢你，雷特。好吧，珍娜，我觉得我们应该休息一下，然后回来播放我们对戴夫·罗杰斯的采访。太棒了。然后在采访完戴夫之后，我们将剖析我们漏掉的所有事情——我们所有的“第二杯”。
Oh, please do. Please request it. Please do. Also, the old 97s just released their new album called 12th, which features the song Turn Off the TV. And guess what? Speaking of music videos. I make a little cameo in that, too. Holy cow, Rhett. I think you might need a few more office ladies in your videos. Oh, I hope so. I filmed it at my house and I sent in the footage. It's really cool. You have to look for me. I'm on one of the TVs. It's like a little Easter egg, but we love you, Rhett. Thank you so much, Rhett. Well, Jenna, I think we should take a little break and then come back and play our interview with Dave Rogers. I love it. And then after our interview with Dave, we will break down all those things that we missed all of our second drinks.
戴夫·罗杰斯，非常感谢你。我们很高兴见到你。我很高兴见到你们。有一段时间没见了。我觉得我昨天才刚见过你们，因为我一直在看这部剧，我花在看你们身上的时间可能比宇宙中任何人都多。等等，戴夫，尽管你剪辑过这部剧，而且在生活中花了大约10年的时间非常仔细地看这部剧，但你还是能看下去吗？是的，我在联合播出时看了很多，因为电视上在播，你知道，就像——我不会主动去找来看，但是，你知道，即使你在电视指南上滚动浏览时，也会想，哦，《办公室》，我点进去看看是哪一集。然后不可避免地，我就被吸引进去了。
Dave Rogers, thank you so much. We are so delighted to see you. I'm so excited to see you guys. It's been a little while. I feel like I just saw you yesterday because I watch the show constantly and I've spent probably more time watching you guys than anybody else in the universe. Wait, Dave, you still watch the show even though you edited the show and had to watch the show in great detail for like 10 years of your life. You can still stomach watching it. Yeah, I watched a lot of it in syndication because it's on, you know, like I don't seek it out, but like, you know, even when you're scrolling on the guide on your TV, it's like, oh, office, I click to see what episode it is. And inevitably, I just get sucked in.
不过真的很神奇，现在有那么多小孩子在看这部剧。我的侄子们10岁和8岁，他们在看这部剧。他们很喜欢，还来片场参观过。他们对参观片场完全没有记忆了。我说，我有你们的照片。我不得不把你们赶出片场。你们到处乱跑，往地板上跳，你知道的，是的。戴夫，剧集杀青时我偷了剧本圣经，但我觉得你就是一个行走的剧本圣经。我觉得你就是人形的剧本圣经。我不认为有谁比你更了解我们剧集的细节了。所以你来了我们真的很兴奋。哇，压力好大。我必须说，曾经有一段时间，我对这部剧的了解比任何人都多，但已经过去几年了，我现在看到那些琐事
It's amazing though, how so many kids watch the show now. My nephews are 10 and 8 and they watch the show. They love it and they came to visit the set. They have no recollection of visiting the set or anything. I'm like, I have pictures of you guys. I had to throw you off the set. You were running around and diving on the floor and, you know, yeah. Dave, I stole the show Bible when the show wrapped, but I think you are a walking show Bible. I think you are the show Bible in human form. I don't think there's anyone who knows more about the details of our show than you. So we're really excited you're here. Wow, that's a lot of pressure. I gotta say at one point, I didn't know the show better than anybody, but it's been a few years and I see now like trivia
问题，以及粉丝们写的内容，我就想，哦，天哪，是的，我不记得那个了。我最好去查一下诸如此类的事情。好吧，粉丝们非常高兴你能来，戴夫，他们为你发了成吨的问题，我们迫不及待地想要深入探讨了。我很兴奋。我们要和戴夫·罗杰斯进行一次深度专访吗？深度专访。好吧，戴夫，我们总是喜欢问大家的第一件事是，你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？你知道的，我在电视界做过很久的助理剪辑师。我从《宋飞传》开始，在那之后，我做了一档叫《新闻广播》的节目。我喜欢《新闻广播》。我喜欢《新闻广播》。我剪辑了《宋飞传》的片段秀。所以如果你看过在剧集大结局前不久播出的那个一小时长的片段秀，那是我第一个独立剪辑署名。然后，在《新闻广播》中，我是助理剪辑师，但也开始进行剪辑。但当时的制片经理是一个名叫肯·扎博纳克的人。哇，肯全书。是的。所以肯是制片经理，我们一直保持着联系，我和他在其他项目上也有过合作。后来某个时候，我又回到了《宋飞传》。我在做 DVD 的所有花絮。肯发了一封电子邮件说，嘿，我手头有个系列剧给你。看一看。这是试播集。我觉得你很适合节目统筹格雷格·丹尼尔斯。所以我说，好吧。我看了试播集，当时——而且我没看过英国版的剧集。我没有，我没有看过英国版或类似的东西。我是
questions and just what fans write and I'm like, oh, God, yeah, I don't remember that. I better check on that and stuff like that. Well, the fans are super excited you're here, Dave, and they send in tons and tons of questions for you and we cannot wait to just dive into it. I'm excited. Should we do a deep dive with Dave Rogers? Deep dive. Well, Dave, the first thing we always like to ask people is how did they come to get their job on the office? You know, I worked as an assistant editor in television for a long time. I started on Seinfeld and then after that, I did a show called News Radio. I love News Radio. I love News Radio. I cut the clip show for Seinfeld. So if you ever watched the hour long clip show that aired
以一张白纸的身份加入的，我看了试播集，然后我想，哦天哪，他的关系是如此的，你知道的，让人尴尬，尤其是他和你之间的关系，珍娜，一开始通过信息，还有他跟你说话的方式诸如此类，他怎么能突然变脸。就像，你知道的，甚至在那个谈薪水的场景里，就像，是的，我们都可以加薪。而他却说，今天不行，帕姆，今天不行。我当时就想，哦天哪。所以我见到了格雷格。我想我是跟他在片场见面的。你知道，我想他们当时在那儿写剧本，那里有办公室。所以，你知道的，最初的那个大楼，在洛斯塞纳加和杰斐逊附近，第一季的拍摄地。对，对。
right before the series finale, that was my first solo editing credit. And then at News Radio, I was an assistant editor, but I started editing as well. But the line producer was a man by the name of Kent Zabornak. Wow, Kent's a pedia. Yeah. So Kent was a line producer and we always stayed in touch and I worked on other projects with him. And then at some point, I was back at Seinfeld. I was working on all the extras for the DVDs. Kent sent me an email and said, hey, I've got a series for you. Take a look. Here's the pilot. I think you'd be a good fit for the showrunner, Greg Daniels. So I said, okay. And I watched the pilot and I was like, and I hadn't seen the British version of the show. I hadn't, I hadn't watched the British version or anything like that. I was
我们就在外面坐着聊了聊我们的理念，你知道格雷格是怎样的，我们对剪辑和节目的理念等等。我想我立刻就理解了这些角色。我说，我能想象德怀特在他的办公桌上放一个《太空堡垒卡狄加》的毒蛇战机。就像《星际迷航》对德怀特来说太主流、太酷了一样。等等，你是——是你为德怀特这个角色埋下了《太空堡垒卡狄加》的种子吗？我承认这一点。我一直被认为有这个功劳。太棒了。天哪。然后大约在第一季的时候，我想实际上可能是第二季，新版《卡狄加》开始播出了。所以这真的算是，你知道的，汇聚到了一起，你知道的，为了我执导的最后一集——倒数第二集，德怀特在他的办公室里挂了一个《卡狄加》的模型。而且，你知道，他甚至说了一些关于小菲利普的话。他说，他看着《卡狄加》的眼神和我一样。而且，这太棒了。这一切，你知道的，都结合到了一起，我得以接触到《太空堡垒卡狄加》。哇。这是一次深度专访。天哪。我甚至都不知道还有老版和新版《卡狄加》之分。天哪。我真是太孤陋寡闻了。我让你失望了，珍娜。哦，不。我真的很伤心。你现在真是在丢脸。天哪。我只是想说，我见到了格雷格，就是这样。我们一拍即合，他说，好的，加入吧。所以就是
coming in completely fresh and I watched the pilot and I was like, oh my God, just the way his relationship was so, you know, cringy and just his relationship, especially with you, Jenna, at the beginning with, you know, messages and, and just the way he would, he would talk to you and everything like that, how he could turn on a don. You're like, you know, just even in that scene with this, with the salary, like, yeah, we could all use a raise. And he's like, not today, Pam, not today. And I just, I was like, oh my God. So I met with Greg. I think I met him at the set. You know, I think they were writing there and they had offices there. So I was, you know, the original building down, down off Los Yenaga and Jefferson, the season one location. Yeah, yeah.
这样。然后我开始，你知道的，我的第一天是在拍摄《多元化日》的第一天。就是这样。我开始在《多元化日》上进行剪辑。然后，我对试播集做了一些微调。但凯瑟琳·希莫夫才是剪辑试播集的人。她在那上面做得非常棒。所以我加入进来，我们为了播出对一些东西做了一点点微调。但我从——你知道的，从《多元化日》一直做到大结局。哇。好吧，听着，很多粉丝想了解你的工作流程，戴夫。比如，当你坐下来开始剪辑一集节目时，你做的第一件事是什么？当你拿到一集的所有素材时，你会得到多少小时的素材？
We just, we just sat outside and talked just about our like philosophies, you know, how Greg is, just our philosophies on editing and shows and things like that. And I just, I think I really understood the characters right away. And I said, I could see Dwight having a Battlestar Galactic Viper on his desk. Like Star Trek was too mainstream and cool for Dwight. Wait, were you, did you plant the seed for Battlestar Galactica for Dwight as a character? I do take that. I have been credited with that. That's amazing. Oh my gosh. And then at about the time, like season one, I think actually probably season, season two, I think the new Galactica had started airing. So that's, that's really kind of, you know, came together, you
你如何组织这些素材？我的意思是，你如何开始构建一集节目？我们通常会说，开始着手处理一集节目有几种不同的方法。其中一种方法就是开始看日常素材。开始看素材。我只会看镜头，我可能会记下笔记。有时我只是，你知道的，胡乱写下一些小东西，比如，哦，我喜欢帕姆这个反应。或者，哦，这太棒了。你知道，我们在安吉拉或凯文身上拍到了那个镜头，无论是什么。然后其他时候，当我边看边发现某个镜头——通常需要几个镜头才能真正进入状态。但有时，你知道，你会得到第一条素材的那种小魔力。然后我就把它扔进时间线里。
know, for the final episode that I directed the, the penultimate episode Dwight hangs a Galactica model in his, in his office. And, you know, he even says things about a little Philip. He's like, he looks at the Galactica the same way I do. And, you know, it's great. It just all, you know, it all kind of came together that I got to, got to deal with Battlestar Galactica. Wow. This is a deep dive. Oh man. I didn't even know there was an old versus new Galactica. Oh my gosh. That's how out of the loop I am. I disappointed you. Jenna. Oh no. I'm really sad. You're embarrassing yourself right now. Oh my god. I was just gonna say, so I met with Greg and that was it. We just, we just hit it off and he's like, all right, come on board. So that
我把它放进去。然后问题就来了，好吧，什么比这个更好？什么部分更好？你知道的，因为你可以放入一整条镜头，然后说，好吧，现在我要逐行逐句地检查，看看有什么比这个更好？什么，你知道的，有没有更好的镜头？然后你在寻找，你知道的，反应，你在寻找，甚至是一些即兴笑话诸如此类。但很多时候，你知道的，一个镜头有其自然的流动性。所以你得到了它，你把它放进去，而且，你知道的，大部分内容我们不会跨镜头剪辑。这就好比，哦，就是这个，他们渐入佳境，状态正佳，你知道的。有时，你知道的，我们会做的一些事情是，你知道的，如果某个反应很慢，
was it. And then I started, you know, my first day there was when the first day of shooting Diversity Day. And that was it. I started, you know, editing on Diversity Day. And then, and I tweaked the pilot a little bit. But it was Catherine Himoff who edited the pilot. And she did, she did an amazing job on that. And so I just came in just, we changed a couple things for, for broadcast very slightly. But I started from, from, you know, Diversity Day to the finale. Wow. Okay. Well, listen, a lot of fans wanted to know about your process, Dave. Like, when, when do you sit down to start editing an episode? What's the first thing you do? Like, when you get all of the footage from an episode, how many hours of footage do you get?
或者在某个角度上类似的情况，然后我们切换到另一个角度，我们可以把内容提上来。或者如果对话中有停顿，我可以切到一个反应镜头，然后把音频稍微提前一点，只是为了，你知道的，加快一点节奏。但总体而言，这只是，你知道的，看什么，什么才是，你知道的，最好的镜头？什么很有趣？是什么让我笑？这就是，你知道的，我所采用的。我记得在片场时，我们会拍一个感觉棒极了的镜头。就像我们进入了状态。然后，无论是哪个导演，都会说，哦，把那个圈起来，瓦达。所以你会从瓦达那里得到那些，对吧？就像你会得到所有那些文件，上面写着，哦，这是格雷格这一场戏中最喜欢的镜头。
How do you organize the footage? I mean, how do you begin to build an episode? There's a couple different ways that I would, you know, start attacking an episode, as we would say. One way is to just start watching dailies. Just start watching the footage. And I'll just watch takes and I may write down notes. And sometimes I'll just, you know, just scribble little things like, Oh, I like this Pam reaction. Or Oh, this was great. You know, we got the shot on, on Angelo or Kevin or, you know, whatever it was. And then other times, like as I'm watching, if I see something like a take, a lot of times it takes a few takes to really get in. But sometimes, you know, you get that magic of the first take to little things. But then I'll just throw it into the, the timeline.
你会用那个吗？是的。是的。很多时候，我的意思是，这很难。有时导演会说，哦，把那个圈起来，把这个圈起来，但那是一个七分钟长的镜头。你不知道，他们可能会说，比如，把这个圈起来，比如，你知道的，德怀特在这里说了这句台词。然后，导演就会说，哦，那挺好的。所以，你知道的，你把它当作一个指南，看看他们喜欢什么。但有时我们没有得到具体的信息，关于，好吧，他们在那个镜头里到底喜欢什么？因为，你知道，听着，剪辑这部剧最难的事情之一，我坦诚地说，是我们有着过多的素材。就像很多时候你会想，天哪，哪个更好？有时这关乎表演，你知道的，
And I'll lay it in. And then it's a question of like, Okay, what beats this? What, what, what part is better? You know, because you can lay in a whole take and then say, All right, now I'm going to take it even line by line and just see what beats this? What's, you know, is, are there any takes that are better? And then you're, you're looking for, you know, reactions, and you're looking for, you know, even all to jokes, things like that. But a lot of times, you know, there's a natural flow to a take. So you, you get it, you, you lay it in and, and, you know, large portions, we don't cross takes. And it's just like, Oh, this is it, they're, they hit it and they're rolling, you know. And sometimes, you know, some of the things we would do is, you know, if there's a reaction that's slow,
比如这个表演太棒了。那个太棒了。有点不同。有时，你知道的，这个笑话很棒。或者有时，你知道的，那个笑话很棒。然后，你知道的，不同的笑话，你知道的，我们有一个糖果袋，里面装着所有这些备用镜头诸如此类，你知道的。我知道我们通常花一周时间拍摄一集。你有多长时间来剪辑一集？剪辑师没有制作工时。我们不会像早上五六点那样去弄妆发之类的。我们大概十点、十点半才晃悠着来。我记得。你知道，也许先玩一局《使命召唤》安顿下来。然后我们开始着手处理日常素材。但接着你会在那儿待到半夜或者晚上十点。是的。是的。随着我们
or something like that on the, you know, we're on one angle, then we go to the other, we can pull, pull stuff up. Or if there was a pause in dialogue, I can cut to a reaction and I can bring the audio in a little earlier, just to, you know, pace things up a little bit. But, but overall, it was just, you know, just looking what, what are the, you know, what's the best take? What's funny? What makes me laugh? And that's, you know, that's what I go with. I remember being on set, and we would do a take that felt fantastic. Like we were in the groove. And then, and then whoever the director was, or would say, Oh, circle that one, Vada. So you would get those from Vada, right? Like you would get all of those documents that were like, Oh, this was Greg's favorite take of this scene.
深入到剧集制作中，如果我们需要锁定一集或者剪出一个电视台版本，就会有一些很晚很晚的夜晚。很多时候，你知道的，比方说，在我们周五完成拍摄后，可能会在接下来的周四或周五完成，你知道的。但随着季度的发展，就像你在做粗剪，但你同时也在做电视台版本，你在做，你知道的，制片人版本，你在锁定内容。所以它会累积起来，你同时在处理多集节目，每件事的进度都会稍微放慢一点，你知道的，就像，好吧，这里的粗剪或者导演剪辑版会稍微延迟一点。但我们设法按时完成了所有事情。所以，那是一件好事。我觉得我们的音效师山姆·凯弗现在正在听，心里会想，哦，我懂。哦，我懂。因为我们确实，我们聊了一会儿。而山姆必须经历这一切。
And did you use that? Yeah. Yeah. A lot of times, I mean, it was tough. Sometimes the director would say, Oh, circle that, circle this, but it's like a seven minute take. And you don't know, they might have said, like, circle this, like, you know, Dwight said this here, this line. And, you know, the director was, Oh, that was good. So, you know, you don't know, you use it as a guide and see what, what did they like. But sometimes we didn't get the specific information of, well, what, what exactly did they like in that take? Because, you know, listen, one of the hardest things of cutting the show. And I say this with all honesty was, we had an embarrassment of riches. Like a lot of times you're like, God, what's better? And sometimes it was like performance, you know,
好吧，我觉得人们没有意识到的一点，戴夫是，并不是说你拿到素材然后剪辑一下就完成了。你剪辑完交给导演，导演给你意见。然后你重新剪辑交给制片人，制片人给你意见。然后你们还得把它交给制片厂和电视台。人们不断地对这些不同的剪辑版本给你意见。一集节目会经历多少不同的剪辑版本？我们每集大概会做五个版本，
like this performance is great. This one's great. It's a little different. Sometimes, you know, this joke is great. Or sometimes, you know, this joke is great. And then, you know, different jokes, you know, we had, we had the candy bag where we would have all these alts and things like that, you know. I know that we would spend one week shooting the episode. How long did you have to edit an episode? Editors don't have production hours. We wouldn't come in at like five a.m. or six a.m. to get makeup and hair and all that. We roll in at like 10, 1030. I remember. You know, maybe settle in with a good game of Call of Duty. And then we start attacking the dailies. But then you're there until like midnight or 10 o'clock at night. Yeah. Yeah. As we would get
但有时会更多。有时，你知道的，我们会处理场景，你知道的，就像，基本上我们会构建粗剪，这意味着我们会构建所有包含进去的内容。很多时候我们会拥有，我会说大约60小时的素材。我的意思是，你们会拍摄，你知道的，拍摄一周，你知道的，所以就像五天，每天12小时的素材，你知道的。而且，你知道的，助理剪辑师们太棒了，因为他们会，你知道的，我们在视频上拍摄。而且很多时候你还记得我们在镜头之间拍摄时相机还在运转。我们不会喊“咔”和“行动”，因为那会花更长的时间。所以助手们会把那些东西剪掉，他们会合并素材，为我们做好准备。但那仍然是，你知道的，很多小时的素材需要过一遍。然后它会交个导演，导演会更换镜头，他们会改变一些时机，你知道的，他们可能会做一些修剪，让它更紧凑、更短。然后，你知道的，它会交给制片人，很多时候它会交给编剧或者格雷格会立刻看。很多时候格雷格会说，你知道的，要么，你知道的，你现在为什么不自己剪一个版本呢。所以我会在粗剪中取最好的东西，在导演剪辑版中取最好的东西，制作我自己的版本，也抽出一小部分时间。有时编剧会有一些意见，他们会说，嘿，你为什么不试试这个或者做那个。
deeper into the series, and if we needed to lock an episode or get a network cut out, there were some, there were some late, late nights. And a lot of times, you know, after, let's say after, you know, we finish shooting on a Friday, it might be done the next Thursday or Friday, you know. But then as the season would, would build up, like you're doing assemblies, but you're also doing network cuts, you're doing, you know, producers cuts and you're locking things. So it would build up, you were working on multiple episodes and everything would kind of slow down a little bit, you know, the, just like, okay, it's going to be a little bit of a delay on this assembly here or this director's cut. But we managed, we managed to get everything done on time.
如果我喜欢，我就会照做，把它放进剪辑版里。如果我不喜欢，我可能会做一下，把它当作一个备用镜头，只是为了展示给他们看，展示给格雷格看，然后我可以解释说，嘿，这就是为什么我没有这么做。我觉得那样更好。但它在这里，很容易替换进出。然后它会交到格雷格手里，他会，你知道的，我们会做，你知道的，所谓的电视台版本，发给电视台，他们会给出意见，然后它会再次返回，我们就会锁定剧集。但这与每个人都合作得非常紧密。我不得不说，你知道的，从导演、制片人、编剧、制片厂到电视台，我们所有人都在努力制作出最好的节目。我记得在片场时，有时格雷格会
So that was, that was a good thing. I feel like our sound engineer, Sam Kever, right now is listening and being like, Oh, I know. Oh, I know. Cause we do, we chat for, for a bit. And Sam has to go through all of it. Well, I think something people don't realize, Dave, is it's not like you just would get footage and then you edit it and it's done. You edit it and you give it to the director who gives you notes. And then you re-edit it and give it to the producer who gives you notes. And then you guys would have to turn it into the studio and into the network. And people are constantly giving you notes on these different cuts. How many different cuts would an episode go through? We probably take about five cuts per episode,
说，嘿，能让戴夫·罗杰斯来片场吗？因为他们当时正在拍一个场景，他们需要你，需要你在片场的剪辑师眼光，因为他们想听听你的意见，关于，好吧，我们是这样拍的。在剪辑中行得通吗？然后你会来到片场。我一直觉得这真的很有趣。格雷格总是谈论他是如何将所有世界融合在一起的。就像他把编剧带到那个，你知道的，编剧成了演员。而且，你知道的，他把剪辑师带到片场，这很好。所以我和演员剧组非常熟悉。很高兴我们都在同一区域拍摄。格雷格会说，嘿，你能来看看这个吗？你知道的，有时是关于连贯性。这些东西在剪辑中能连上吗？有时只是
but sometimes more. And sometimes, you know, we'd work scenes, you know, like, you know, like basically we would build the assembly and that means we would build everything that was in. And a lot of times we would have like, I would say somewhere like 60 hours of footage. I mean, you guys would shoot for the, you know, shoot a week, you know, so it was like five days, like 12 hours, you know, of footage. And, you know, the assistant editors were great because they would, you know, we would shoot on video. And a lot of times you remember how we would roll in between takes the camera would still be rolling. We wouldn't call cut and action because that would take longer. And so the assistants would cut that stuff out, they would consolidate the
关于，这个镜头能剪辑吗？如果我们这样做并从这个角度拍摄，这能剪辑到我们稍后要拍摄的内容吗？所以，我的意思是，他并不总是需要我。有时只是为了证实他已经有想法的事情。然后我会说，是的，是的，那行得通。那行得通。我的意思是，就是这样。但每个人都知道自己在做什么。我的意思是，我们有，你知道的，对兰德尔·因霍恩和马特·索恩我怎么赞美都不为过。我的意思是，我们有非常棒的，你知道的，摄影师。我的意思是，整个剧组真的，我觉得每个人都喜欢呆在那里，都喜欢这部剧，每个人都在非常努力地工作，你知道的，让一切，让一切都运转得非常好。
footage, get it ready for us. But it was still like, you know, a lot of hours of footage to go through. And then it would go to the director and the director would swap takes and they would change some things timing and, you know, they may make some trims and make it a little tighter and shorter. Then, you know, it would go to the producers, it would go to a lot of times it would go to the writers or Greg would look at it right away. And a lot of times Greg would say, you know, either, you know, why don't you do your own cut now. So I would take the best things from the assembly and the best things from the director's cut, make my own cut, take some time out a little bit too. Sometimes the writers would have some notes, they would say, Hey, why don't you try this or do this.
确实如此。是的，确实如此。好吧，我想说，戴夫，自从我离开《办公室》以后，在我接下来的任何其他项目中，我都从来没有见过剪辑师。真的。我从来没见过他们。我不认识他们。我曾试图像我们过去那样去拜访你的剪辑室一样，去拜访一下他们的剪辑室。而他们似乎很困惑。我做过的那些节目的制片人对这种做法并不热情。就好像他们不希望演员看到剪辑过程。他们不希望演员——我不知道。这就好像，好像我们一看到未经剪辑的最终版场景，就会大发雷霆一样。我不知道。我想说的是，我们当时拥有的那种关系，我的意思是，我从来没有见过一个节目统筹像格雷格那样，以那种温暖和包容的方式对待剧组、演员和编剧团队。我觉得很多剪辑师和制片人都害怕演员进入剪辑室，原因就像你说的，哦，如果有什么东西没剪好或者没准备好，然后他们，你知道的，他们会抱怨，或者我们是不是不得不，你知道的——并且有一种恐惧，那就是，好吧，我们必须重新拍摄，因为某个耍大牌的演员，你知道的，说我们必须这样做之类的。你知道，对我们来说，我觉得首先说明我们的剪辑室在哪里很重要，我们在那一层，就像迈克尔·斯科特的停车位所在的位置，我的剪辑室就在那个标志的另一边。椒盐卷饼日，椒盐卷饼日，它们都在你们的走廊上。迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司也在
And I would say if I liked it, I would do it if and put it in the cut. If I didn't like it, I might do it and just have it as an alt just to show them to show Greg and I could say like, Hey, this is why I didn't do this. I felt like this was better. But here it is, it's easy to swap in or out. Then it would go to Greg, he would, you know, we would do, you know, what was called the network cut, send it to the network, they would give notes, and then it would go back again and we would lock the show. But it was very collaborative with everybody. I'll have to say, you know, from from the directors, the producers, the writers, the studio and the network, we were all just trying to make the best show. I remember being on set and there'd be times where Greg would
如果我喜欢，我就会把它剪辑进去。如果我不喜欢，我可能会做出来留作备选，用来展示给格雷格看，我可以告诉他：“嘿，这就是我没用这个镜头的原因，我觉得那个更好。但它就在这儿，随时可以替换。”然后它会交到格雷格手里，我们会做所谓的“电视台剪辑版”，发给电视台，他们会给出意见，接着再拿回来，最后锁定节目。但整个过程大家的合作非常默契。我必须得说，无论是导演、制片人、编剧、工作室还是电视台，我们大家的目标都只是为了把节目做到最好。我记得在片场有时格雷格会
say, Hey, can we get Dave Rogers on set because they were shooting a scene and they needed you, your editor's eye on the set because they wanted your opinion about, Okay, we're shooting it this way. Is it going to work in editing? And you would come down to set. And I always found that really fascinating. Greg always talks about how he, he brought all the worlds together. Like he brought writers onto that, you know, writers were actors. And, you know, it was, it was nice that he brought editors onto the set. You know, so I knew the cast and the crew very well. You know, it was great that we were all filming in the same area. Greg would say, Hey, can you come and look at this? You know, sometimes it was about continuity. Will things track in editing? Sometimes it was just
说：“嘿，能让戴夫·罗杰斯来一趟片场吗？”因为他们正在拍一场戏，他们需要在片场有你这位剪辑师的眼光，想听听你的意见：“好吧，我们是这样拍的，这在剪辑里行得通吗？”然后你就会来到片场。我一直觉得这真的非常迷人。格雷格总是谈到他是如何将所有部门融合在一起的。比如他让编剧去客串，你知道，编剧们也演戏。而且，他能让剪辑师也来到片场，这真的很棒。所以我和演员、剧组人员都非常熟悉。我们都在同一个区域拍摄，这太棒了。格雷格会说：“嘿，你能来看看这个吗？”有时候是关于连戏问题，剪辑时这些东西能连上吗？有时只是
about like, will this, will this shot cut? If we do this and we shoot from this angle, will this cut to something that we're going to shoot later? So, I mean, it wasn't, it wasn't that often that he would, you know, need me. Sometimes it was just to confirm something that he already, you know, had a thought on. And I'd say, Yeah, yeah, that'll work. That'll work. I mean, that was it. But everybody kind of knew what they were doing. I mean, we had, you know, I can't say enough about Randall Einhorn and Matt Sohn. I mean, we had fantastic, you know, camera guys. And I mean, the whole crew was just really, I think everybody just loved being there and loved the show that everybody was just working really hard, you know, to make everything, everything work really well.
关于“这个镜头能剪辑吗？如果我们这样做，从这个角度拍，它能和我们稍后要拍的画面剪辑到一起吗？”所以，我的意思是，他并不经常需要我。有时只是为了确认他自己心里已经有底的想法。我会说：“对，对，那样行得通，那样行得通。”差不多就是这样。但每个人都知道自己在做什么。我的意思是，对于兰德尔·艾因霍恩和马特·索恩，我怎么赞美都不为过。我们的摄影师太棒了。我的意思是，整个剧组真的很棒，我觉得每个人都喜欢在那里工作，都热爱这部剧，所以每个人都在非常努力地工作，确保所有事情都进展顺利。
It really did. Yeah, it really did. Well, I wanted to say, Dave, not on a single one of my other projects since I left the office, have I ever met the editors? Exactly. I've never met them. I don't know them. I've tried to kind of pop in to the edit base, the way we used to come and pop into yours. And they seem confused. The the producers of the shows that I've done that have been not warm to that. It's like they don't want the actor to see the editing process. They don't want the actors. I don't know. It's like, as if we're going to go in there and lose our shit, because we saw a scene to, you know, uncut in its finished version. I don't know. I guess what I'm saying is just that the relationship that we had, I mean, I just I have never seen a showrunner
确实如此。是的，真的如此。嗯，我想说的是，戴夫，自从我离开《办公室》之后，在我之后的每一个项目里，我再也没有见过剪辑师。真的，我从未见过他们，我不认识他们。我曾试图去剪辑室串门，就像我们以前去你那里串门那样。但他们显得很困惑。我参与过的其他节目的制片人对这种事并不热心。就像他们不希望演员看到剪辑过程一样。他们不希望演员……我不知道，就好像我们会因为看到一个未完成的、粗剪的场景而在那儿发飙一样。我不知道。我想说的是，我们之间拥有的那种关系，我从来没见过哪个剧集运作人
facilitate that kind of warmth and inclusion with a crew and cast and writing staff the way Greg did. I think a lot of editors and producers are afraid of actors coming into the edit bay for what you said, like, oh, if something's uncut or not ready, and then they, you know, they complain, or do we have to, you know, and there's that fear of like, well, we have to reshoot because some diva actor, you know, says we have to do this or something. You know, for us, I think it's important to say where our edit bays were, first of all, we were right there on the first floor, like where Michael Scott's, you know, parking spot is my edit bay was on the other side of that sign. Pretzel Day, Pretzel Day, they were all down your hallway. Michael Scott Paper Company was
能像格雷格那样，在剧组、演员和编剧团队中营造出那种温馨和包容的氛围。我想很多剪辑师和制片人都害怕演员进入剪辑室，就像你说的，哦，如果有什么东西没剪好或还没准备好，然后他们就开始抱怨，或者我们是不是不得不……，那种恐惧就是“哦，我们得重新拍摄，因为某个耍大牌的演员说我们必须这么做或者别的什么”。你知道，对于我们来说，我觉得首先有必要说明我们的剪辑室在哪里，我们在那一楼，就像迈克尔·斯科特的停车位所在的位置，我的剪辑室就在那个标志的另一边。“椒盐卷饼日！椒盐卷饼日！”它们都在你们的走廊尽头，迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司就在
our, I mean, our bathroom and that doorway there, you know, those were, you know, we're right down the hall from caffeine corner. So anytime we shot like at the warehouse or in the parking lot, you know, the cast would come in and hang out. And we always, listen, I always loved going to set, but it was always great when having you guys come in. And, you know, I loved showing you guys things too. Like, oh, take a look at this and see this. And I think also, listen, I think editors, you know, Greg said something, he's like, you know, you're really like the gatekeeper, because I would see stuff before anybody else would. And so I could communicate, especially, you know, you have actors that are, you know, if they're, hey, did this work? Or, you know,
我们的，我是说，我们的浴室还有那扇门，你知道，那些，你知道，我们离咖啡角（caffeine corner）只有一条走廊的距离。所以每当我们在仓库或停车场拍摄时，你知道，演员们就会过来串门。而且我们总是，听着，我总是喜欢去片场，但你们能来总是最棒的。而且，你知道，我也喜欢向你们展示各种东西。比如，哦，来看看这个，瞧瞧这个。而且我也觉得，听着，我觉得剪辑师，你知道，格雷格（Greg）说过一句话，他说，你知道，你真的就像守门人，因为我会比任何人都先看到素材。所以我可以进行沟通，特别是，你知道，你们有演员会，嘿，这行得通吗？或者，你知道，
when you have things, you know, everybody had different things that their character was doing too. Like you could see the evolution of Pam or the evolution of Angela. So if I could communicate, hey, this, this romantic scene that you played today was really good. It was really romantic and really funny. You know, I can say like, oh, this was, you know, I can communicate that to you. There's no, there's no secrets. I'm not trying to hide anything. And I think it's, it's good to, to let the cast know. You know, so those, I think that was kind of the relationship that we had. And we were always, always welcoming. I love what you guys would hang out like in between takes and just sit on the couch. And, you know, we would just just chat away. I know Jen and I have talked
当你有一些东西时，你知道，每个人角色的行为也各不相同。比如你可以看到帕姆（Pam）的演变，或者安吉拉（Angela）的演变。所以如果我能沟通，嘿，你今天演的这场浪漫戏真的很棒。真的很浪漫而且非常搞笑。你知道，我可以这样说，哦，这个是，你知道，我可以把这个传达给你。没有什么，没有什么秘密。我不是想隐瞒什么。而且我认为，让演员们知道这一点，这很好，很好。你知道，所以这些，我认为这就是我们当时的关系。而且我们总是，总是热情欢迎。我喜欢你们在镜头转换间隙闲逛，就坐在沙发上。然后，我知道，我们就会天南海北地聊天。我知道詹（Jen）和我聊过
about this. We have so many fond memories of like multiple members of the cast, just piling in on your, you had that black leather sofa, you know, just to pile in on it. And you would show us all these different takes and we'd be howling with laughter. And Greg would sometimes be like, hey, which one did you like? We're trying to decide between these two, which I think is really unheard of, right? That actually brings up a good point. People have asked, you know, the mythology of Greg Daniels, does he AB things a lot? Does he have different versions? And it's like, yes, he does. And ABing is kind of like, it's, you know, it's kind of like going to the eye doctor or when you, when you have those things on your eyes and he's like, okay, is this better or is
这个。我们有太多美好的回忆，比如多位演员直接挤到你的那张黑色皮沙发上，你知道，就是挤上去。然后你会向我们展示所有不同的镜头，我们笑得前仰后合。而格雷格有时会说，嘿，你们喜欢哪个？我们正试图在这两个之间做出选择，我觉得这真的是前所未闻的，对吧？这实际上提出了一个很好的观点。人们问过，你知道，格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）的神话，他经常做A/B测试吗？他有不同的版本吗？答案是，是的，他确实有。而A/B测试有点像，它，你知道，这有点像去看眼科医生，或者当你，当你眼睛戴上那些镜片，然后他会问，好吧，是这样更好，还是
this better? Is this better or is this better? It's so minimal. It's such a minimal difference. And so Greg, you know, we would, we would always like have, especially like in the early seasons, you know, the pilot season one, you know, he would, he would always, you know, want to see things like different versions of things and he'd want to show these to people. So, you know, first it'd be like, oh, let's bring in the writers. But then he wanted like a wider array of people. So he would talk to the cast. He would show them things. He would bring in though, like the real accounting department for the show. He wanted like people who were like non, you know, creatives, so to speak, to look at it. And I remember we were, we were editing season one, we were out of our,
这样更好？是这样更好，还是这样更好？差距太微小了。这是非常微小的差别。所以格雷格，你知道，我们总是，特别是像在早期的几季里，你知道，试播集第一季，你知道，他总是，你知道，想要看不同的版本，而且他想把这些展示给人们。所以，你知道，首先会是，哦，把编剧们叫进来。但接着他想要更广泛的人群。所以他会和演员交谈。他会把东西展示给他们。不过，他还会把剧组真正的会计部门的人请来。他想要那些，你知道，非创意人员，可以说是这样的人来看看。我记得我们，我们在剪辑第一季时，我们离开了，
out of the stages where we were at, you know, out of that building and we were like editing in some E office suite and there were just other people in the building working and he had, he brought like a cleaning lady, a shoe salesman and someone else to watch diversity day. Like, what do you think of this? What do you think of this? Like, yeah, good, good. You know, he wanted, he didn't know if to slap it, but you know, when Mindy slap Steve was too harsh, he didn't know like, you know, certain jokes were playing and things like that. So, yeah, he would always want to see, you know, what was the, what was the better version and really get a, get a sense of, you know, he wanted to pull people and find out what, what people thought. And now I don't know if you guys remember
离开了我们当时所在的摄影棚，你知道，离开了那栋大楼，我们在某个E区办公室套房里剪辑，大楼里还有其他人在工作，他竟然找来了一个清洁女工、一个鞋店售货员和其他什么人来观看《多元化日》（Diversity Day）。就像，你觉得这个怎么样？你觉得这个怎么样？就像，嗯，好，好。你知道，他不知道该不该打耳光，但你知道，当明迪（Mindy）打史蒂夫（Steve）耳光时显得太严厉了，他不知道，你知道，某些笑话效果如何之类的事情。所以，是的，他总是想看看，你知道，哪个是更好的版本，并且真正去了解，你知道，他想进行民意调查，弄清楚大家是怎么想的。现在我不知道你们是否还记得
the main title music, but he went out to the cast. He's like, Hey, pitch songs. So everybody pitched songs and then it got narrowed down. I had to cut like 21 different versions of the main title. Like, you had a song, you had a song. This was, you know, because I had to cut the pick. It wasn't like I could just lay the song in. I had to cut the picture to the, to the song. The song. Yeah. Sorry, Dave. John Krzysko, I remember, he had a good song by Sloan that was almost, you know, that was a contender. I mean, there were a lot of, a lot of good songs. But of course, ultimately we went with the first song that we got submitted to us from a composer, which was the theme as we all know it to the office. And now that was, you know,
片头曲，但他去问了演员们。他说，嘿，推荐歌曲吧。于是每个人都推荐了歌曲，然后范围缩小了。我不得不把片头剪辑出大约21个不同的版本。就像，你有一首歌，你有一首歌。这是，你知道的，因为我必须根据剪辑来选。我不是随便把歌放进去就行。我必须根据歌曲来剪辑画面。这首歌。是的。对不起，戴夫（Dave）。我记得约翰·克里兹科（John Krzysko）有一首斯隆（Sloan）乐队的好歌，差点就入选了，你知道，那是候选曲目。我的意思是，有很多，很多好歌。但当然，最终我们还是选择了从一位作曲家那里收到的第一首歌，也就是我们大家都知道的办公室主题曲。现在那是，你知道的，
I pitched modest mouth, like we'll all float on. Okay. Do you remember that song? Yeah. Yes. I think it was being used by like the CW or something. It was, it was. Oh my gosh, Dave, you are just like a walking treasure. Do you remember any other scenes that you guys, that you tried multiple versions of? Well, for example, I know that there was that the parking lot proposal between Jim and Pam, for example, there was a big debate about whether or not we should hear the audio or not hear the audio. Did you have to cut two versions of that? Dean Holland cut that. He, Dean cut that scene. We cut two versions of that, of that scene, you know, one where you would hear the audio and one where you didn't. And we left the mix that night. And the one that
我推荐了莫德斯特·鼠（Modest Mouse）的歌，就像我们会浮起来的。好吧。你还记得那首歌吗？是的。是的。我记得它当时被CW电视台或别的什么地方用过。确实被用过。哦天哪，戴夫，你简直就像一个行走的宝库。你还记得你们尝试过多个版本的其他场景吗？嗯，举个例子，我知道吉姆（Jim）和帕姆（Pam）在停车场求婚的那场戏，例如，关于我们究竟是应该听到声音还是不应该听到声音，曾有过激烈的争论。你必须剪辑两个版本吗？迪恩·霍兰（Dean Holland）剪辑的。迪恩剪辑了那个场景。我们把那个场景剪了两个版本，你知道，一个能听到声音，一个听不到。那天晚上我们完成了混音。其中一个
was going in was the one without audio. Okay. And Greg woke up the next morning and changed his mind. And that was, you know, and that's the one that went in. Ultimately, he, you know, and somebody say, Oh, it was a, it might have been a bolder choice to, you know, to not hear it. But again, I think there's something with the, the satisfaction of the audience of, you know, wanting, wanting to hear this. And, you know, with all the, you still get a sense of with all the noise and the chaos of the trucks going by and the rain and things like that, that it's still feels, you know, distant and dirty. It's not, you know, this, you know, perfectly cinematic moment. Although, you know, ultimately, I think that's what it is. It turned out to be that with
要放进正片的是没有声音的那个。好的。格雷格第二天醒来后改变了主意。然后，你知道的，就是放了那个版本。最终，他，你知道的，有人会说，哦，这是一个，不听声音可能是一个更大胆的选择。但话说回来，我觉得这在某种程度上能满足观众的心理，你知道，观众想要，想要听到这个。而且，你知道，所有的杂音，卡车开过的噪音、雨声以及诸如此类的混乱声音，你仍然能感觉到，你知道，那种距离感和粗糙感。它不是，你知道，这种，你知道的，完美如电影般的时刻。尽管，你知道，最终，我认为事情就是这样。伴随着
all of the chaos going on. There was actually, they were supposed to destroy the lab. The house was supposed to destroy the version without the sound. Like we didn't want it accidentally ending up anywhere. And they didn't. And it almost ended up on the DVDs. Yeah. And Jake oust, who was our associate producer at the time was like, wait a minute, you know, and that was almost a huge problem that it almost made it onto the DVD as the official episode, you know, because that someone grabbed the wrong, you know, master. But yeah, that was, that was one of those things that were where we had different versions. Listen, there are there were, you know, different versions of the shows that we've locked there. You know, there was there was one episode.
所有发生的混乱，它最终变成了那样。实际上，他们本打算销毁实验室。剧组本打算销毁没有声音的版本。就像我们不希望它意外流落到任何地方一样。而他们没有销毁。它差点就上了DVD。是的。杰克·奥斯特（Jake Aust），我们当时的助理制片人，就说，等一下，你知道，这差点酿成大祸，它差点作为官方正片被收录到DVD里，你知道，因为有人拿错了，你知道，母带。但是的，那是，那是我们有不同版本的那些事情之一。听着，有，你知道，我们锁定的剧集有不同的版本。你知道，有一集，
Lice was one of these episodes where I think I started editing it and then Claire Scanlon was finishing it. And I was I think I was directing. And that's why I didn't I didn't lock the episode. And then I went to the mix. And I realized like the show just ended at the end of the episode with Meredith, bald Meredith, taking, you know, asking Pam to go get a drink. And I was like, wait, what what happened to the bar, then go to the bar and sharing a moment and singing. And so I and after the mix, I came back to work. And, you know, I said, Hey, Greg, what happened to the end of the episode? He goes, Oh, did you miss that? I go, Yeah, I kind of did. He goes, Yeah, some other other people did too. He's like, Well, why don't you take a look and see? I just
《长虱子》（Lice）就是其中之一，我想是我开始剪辑的，然后克莱尔·斯坎伦（Claire Scanlon）完成了它。而我当时好像在导演。这就是为什么我没有，我没有锁定这一集。然后我去参加混音。我意识到这一集就这样结束了，以梅雷迪思（Meredith）——秃头的梅雷迪思——要求帕姆陪她去喝一杯结束了。我就想，等等，去酒吧之后发生了什么，然后去酒吧分享时刻并一起唱歌。所以我，在混音之后，我回到工作岗位上，然后，你知道，我说，嘿，格雷格，这一集的结尾怎么回事？他说，哦，你错过那个了吗？我说，嗯，我确实有点错过了。他说，是的，其他人也错过了。他说，好吧，你为什么不看一看呢？我只是
felt like there was some stuff that was too long. And I said, I think I can make some tiny trims. And, and still be able to squeeze that in and not really lose too much. And that's what I did. We I mean, this was a locked episode ready to be ready to be delivered. And we changed it. I was like, you know, I did a new version, kept the ending, I'd have to look to see exactly where I took out a little bit of air or what what pieces I lost. But I felt like ultimately it was a better episode to see Meredith and Pam bonding at this bar. Yeah. Oh, Dave. Thank you. From me personally, doing that scene was in the bar was one of my favorite moments on the show. And I just think I would have been so heartbroken if if that had not made it. Well, yeah, you're welcome. I mean,
觉得有些内容太长了。我说，我想我可以做一些微小的修剪，然后还能把那部分硬塞进去，而且不会损失太多。这就是我所做的。我的意思是，这是一集已经锁定并准备交付的剧集。而我们改变了它。我就像，你知道，我做了一个新版本，保留了结尾，我得去看看我到底是在哪里删掉了一点空白，或者我删掉了哪些片段。但我最终觉得，看到梅雷迪思和帕姆在这个酒吧里建立感情，是一集更好的剧集。是的。哦，戴夫。谢谢你。对我个人而言，在酒吧里拍那场戏是我在剧中经历过最美好的时刻之一。我只是觉得如果那段没能播出来，我一定会心碎的。好吧，是的，不客气。我的意思是，
listen, it was not. Again, it was just a choice originally like, Oh, I think we can, you know, it was still a nice ending before. But I think that this really brought it to a to even a nice a better place at the end. But I remember the writer Nikki Schwartz had a, you know, she was home sick and she got a DVD that said locked, you know, episodes. She was like, Wait a minute, I already got the locked episode. And she watched it. She was she was so happy to see that scene back in there too. She didn't realize what had what had happened. And I was like, Yeah, that was like the one time where I really unlocked something and and and and, you know, made a change like that. Well, I want to ask you about improvisation. What was it like for you to deal with all of our
听着，这并不是。再说一次，最初这只是一个选择，比如，哦，我觉得我们可以，你知道，之前的结尾也挺好。但我认为这实际上让结尾达到了一个更好、更棒的境界。但我记得编剧尼基·施瓦茨（Nikki Schwartz）生病在家，她收到了一张写着“已锁定剧集”的DVD。她当时想，等等，我已经拿到锁定版的剧集了啊。然后她看了。她看到那个场景又出现在里面，高兴极了！她根本不知道发生了什么。而我就说，是的，那是我唯一一次真正解锁某些内容，并且，并且，并且，你知道，做了这样一番修改。好吧，我想问你关于即兴表演的事。作为一个剪辑师，应付我们所有的
improvisation as an editor? It was great. There's no difference to me between improvisation or scripted stuff. And whatever was funniest one. I mean, that was it. If something if someone said something funny, I didn't listen, I never cared who wrote a joke, you know, I never there was never anything like, Oh, this person wrote this or this wrote this, like I didn't. So whatever was, you know, whether it was a line that was written in the script, whether it was something a writer pitched on the set, or whether it was something an actor just came up with, you know, whatever was the funniest is what what we would end up putting into the cut. Who improvised the most, Dave? Or who are some of the people who improvise most often? All of you guys, I think, you know, once
即兴表演是什么体验？太棒了。对我来说，即兴表演和剧本台词没有什么区别。哪个最好笑，哪个就是胜者。我的意思是，就是这样。如果有什么，如果有人说了什么搞笑的话，听着，我从来不在乎是谁写的一个笑话，你知道，我从来，从来没有过那种想法，哦，这是这个人写的，那是那个人写的，我才不管呢。所以无论什么，无论是剧本里写的一句台词，还是编剧在片场临时提议的，又或者是演员自己想出来的，你知道，只要最搞笑的，就是我们最终会放进剪辑里的内容。谁最喜欢即兴发挥，戴夫？或者说有哪些人是最经常即兴发挥的？你们所有人，我想，你知道，一旦
we got comfortable with, you know, especially once we shot the takes that we needed, I think I felt like all of you guys were were the best improvisers. And you could see when when we'd get guest cast come in, who could improvise and who you know, who was not quite as quick, you know, to do it. But I was always impressed. I mean, anybody would, you know, just the way you could react to someone else throwing something new at you was always impressive. I felt like everybody just had the the chops, they were all ready to go. I think, you know, if anything, sometimes people would would crack up. Listen, I have, I have, you know, the audition tapes and the screen test. And that there's a screen to I don't even think this is on the DVDs, but there's there's
我们习惯了，你知道，特别是拍完了我们需要的镜头之后，我觉得你们所有人都是最棒的即兴表演者。而且你能看出，当有客串演员进来时，谁能即兴发挥，谁（你知道的）又没那么快能做到。但我总是印象深刻。我的意思是，任何人，你知道，单凭你对别人抛出的新东西做出反应的方式就总是让人印象深刻。我觉得每个人都有两下子，他们都准备好了。我想，如果真要说有什么的话，有时候大家会笑场。听着，我有，我有，你知道的，试镜磁带和银幕测试。而且有一个银幕测试，我觉得甚至都不在DVD里，但有一个是
one of Steve Carell and Rainn Wilson. And it's so funny. It's it's like an improv about Dwight, you know, Michael is saying Dwight, have you been using my office when I'm not there? And Dwight's like, no, I haven't. He's like, because someone used my coffee mug, he's like, I don't think it was me. He's like, because there was chocolate milk in it. And and just that he's like, and you're the only one who drinks chocolate milk and rain is cracking. But like Steve managed to break rain for a couple seconds. And it's just during the audition, during the audition, just the chemistry test. And it's just beautiful. But you can see like, they're so good right away. Like, just the way Steve is giving glances to the camera. And just the way he's like, you know,
史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）和雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson）的。太搞笑了。它就像是一个关于德怀特（Dwight）的即兴表演，你知道，迈克尔（Michael）说，德怀特，我不在的时候你是不是用了我的办公室？德怀特说，不，我没有。他说，因为有人用了我的咖啡杯，德怀特说，我觉得那不是我。他说，因为里面有巧克力牛奶。而且仅仅是这个，他说，而且只有你喝巧克力牛奶，雷恩就在那儿笑场了。但史蒂夫设法让雷恩笑场了好几秒钟。这正是在试镜期间，在试镜期间，仅仅是化学反应测试。这简直太美妙了。但你能看到，他们一上来就表现得太好了。就像，单凭史蒂夫瞥向摄像机的那种眼神。以及他那种，你知道的，
he's like, look, we have a good relationship. We're friendly and rain goes best friends. And then and Michael's well, you know, friendly. And it's just I was like, wow, just right out of the get go, these guys just have it, you know, there's something special there. We have a fan question that I think people are going to be really excited to hear about. Okay. They wanted to know if you had any go to cast members when you needed a reaction. I love I love going to Leslie anytime I could get, you know, Stanley, you know, give it an eye roll. You know, that was always fantastic. Phyllis, you know, I'm a listen, I'm a fan of everybody. So it was like, well, whoever whoever was appropriate, Kevin, you know,
他说，听着，我们关系很好，我们很友好，雷恩则说，是最好的朋友。然后迈克尔又说，嗯，（普通）友好。我当时就想，哇，刚一开场，这些家伙就拿捏住了，你知道，这里面有些特别的东西。我们有一个粉丝提问，我觉得大家听到会非常兴奋。好的。他们想知道，当你需要一个反应镜头时，你有没有哪几个常用的演员？我喜欢，只要有机会我随时都喜欢去找莱斯利（Leslie），你知道，斯坦利（Stanley）翻个白眼，你知道，那总是棒极了。菲利斯（Phyllis），你知道的，听着，我是所有人的粉丝。所以这就是，无论谁，谁合适就找谁，凯文（Kevin），你知道，
there were times actually here, this is this is kind of an interesting thing, which isn't so much going to reaction shop. But, you know, we would we would do this kind of thing that started, we would do too often at first, where somebody would say something the camera would push in a little, then they'd say something again, the camera would push in a lot. And I think I feel like the cameras love this like kind of trick we would do, but they started doing it a lot very early and and often. And it was like, wait, nothing has, you know, substantiated that like not it hasn't earned this like in this scene. And I remember one time Kevin was saying something and you're standing next to him and what I can't remember exactly
实际上有时候，这里，这是一种挺有趣的情况，这不太算是寻找反应镜头，但是，你知道，我们会做这种一开始用得太频繁的做法，就是某人说了句话，摄像机稍微推近一点，然后他们又说了一句话，摄像机大幅度推近。我觉得摄影师非常喜欢我们这种小把戏，但他们很早就开始频繁地这样做了。这就好像，等等，没有任何铺垫能支撑这一点——就像它在这场戏里还没赚取到这种特写。我记得有一次凯文在说些什么，你正站在他旁边，我记不清具体
now what it was, but he said something offensive. And the camera pushes in, but it like cropped Angela out. And I was like, whoa, whoa, whoa. And I should and luckily there was another take where it didn't. And it's like, yeah, because you want to see Angela's reaction. She's standing there reacting. It wasn't even so much a payoff as a bonus. Do you know what I mean? Like his line was funny. But to see her actually cringe from it at the end in real time, like that's what's like we don't want to lose that kind of thing on the show. So I said, guys, you know, let's let's I just showed some examples. I was like, just be aware of this. A lot of times when you have two people on the same plane, we don't want to lose, you know, what other people are doing
现在是什么内容了，但他说了句冒犯的话。摄像机推近了，但它把安吉拉（Angela）给切出去了。当时我就想，哇，哇，哇。好在还有另一个镜头没有切掉安吉拉。这就对了，因为你想看到安吉拉的反应。她就站在那里做出反应。这甚至与其说是一个包袱（payoff），不如说是一个额外彩蛋。你知道我的意思吗？他的台词很好笑。但看到她在最后实时地做出畏缩的反应，这才是——我们不想在剧中失去这种镜头。所以我就说，各位，你知道，让我们——我展示了一些例子。我当时就说，注意这一点。很多时候，当你们两个人在同一个平面上时，我们不想失去，你知道，其他人正在做的事情，
because reacting is acting. Like we're getting some gold here. Like this is what's he's saying something funny, but her reaction is equally as funny, if not even funnier. And it enhances the whole scene. Well, to be fair, Angela is very tiny. And it must be hard to hold her in a shot with some of these very tall actors on our show. We do have a lot of tall actors, like all these I've gone on set and you know, Rain was super tall, Creed, John was like a giant, you know. Yeah, Brian's so tall. A lot of the Dwight and Angela big moments, he's seated and I'm standing. Yeah. So Dave, another thing that we got a lot of mail about people are very curious to know what were the most challenging aspects of editing the office?
因为反应也是表演。我们在这里拍到了宝贵的素材。这才是重点，他说的话很好笑，但她的反应同样好笑，甚至比他的还要好笑。而且它为主演们增色了整场戏。公平地说，安吉拉个子非常小。要把她和我们剧中那些个子很高的演员框在同一个镜头里，一定很难吧。我们确实有很多高个子演员，就像所有这些，我去过片场，你知道，雷恩超级高，克里德（Creed），约翰（John）简直像个巨人，你知道的。是的，布莱恩（Brian）也非常高。德怀特和安吉拉的很多重头戏里，他坐着而我站着。是的。所以戴夫，关于《办公室》的剪辑，我们收到了很多来信，大家都很好奇，剪辑《办公室》最具挑战性的方面是什么？
The challenging challenging things for editing was just always, you know, getting a lot of footage, you know, sometimes the cameras are moving all over the place. And, you know, because they're just zipping around. It's like when you have a big bullpen scene. And it's like, okay, we're catching this person and this person, it's not the cameras aren't static. I mean, that was part of the joy of our show is that they would move around and find things. And sometimes they would be intentionally late. And, you know, to really feel like that they were working like a documentary. I mean, that was challenging. You know, the chaos of stress relief, you know, the opening for that Dean cut, Dean and I both cut the episode, but he cut the, you know, the fire. People always love
剪辑中最具挑战性的事情，永远都是，你知道，要处理大量的素材，你知道，有时摄像机在到处乱晃，你知道的，因为它们就在周围穿梭。就像你有一个很大的办公大厅（bullpen）场景时。这就好像，好吧，我们要捕捉这个人，还有那个人，摄像机不是静止的。我的意思是，我们剧集的乐趣之一就在于它们会四处移动并捕捉各种东西。有时它们会故意迟到，你知道的，为了真正营造出它们在像纪录片一样工作的感觉得到。我的意思是，这很有挑战性。你知道，缓解压力（Stress Relief）那一集的混乱场面，那一集的开场是迪恩（Dean）剪的，迪恩和我共同剪辑了那一集，但他剪了，你知道，那场火灾。人们总是喜欢
the fire and stress relief. And, you know, to me, like that's a tour de force to seeing all the stuff, all the action and see, you know, there's Michael trying to throw a chair out the window. There's Kevin throwing a chair at the vending machines and, you know, just the fireworks going off and things like that. And just, you know, just the pacing of it, like that's an exciting thing. The finale was tough to cut. I mean, there was so much pressure on the finale. Clara Scanlon and I split cutting the finale and she cut the first half and I cut the second half. And then Greg did something very radical after he saw the assembly. He's like, all right, you guys switch. And he put me on the first half and then Claire on the second half. So I did like
《缓解压力》里的那场火灾。而且，对我来说，这就是一次全能展示，看到所有的东西，所有的动作，看到，你知道，迈克尔试图把一把椅子扔出窗外。凯文把一把椅子扔向自动售货机，你知道的，烟花四射之类的。还有，你知道，它的节奏，这真是一个令人兴奋的东西。大结局（finale）很难剪。我的意思是，大结局的压力太大了。克莱尔·斯坎伦（Claire Scanlon）和我分工剪辑大结局，她剪了前半部分，我剪了后半部分。然后格雷格在看过初剪粗剪（assembly）后做了一个非常激进的决定。他说，好吧，你们俩换一下。他让我负责前半部分，而让克莱尔负责后半部分。所以我做了一个
a polish pass with Greg on the first half and Claire did the second half. And then we combined them and we still like, I still worked on stuff in the end. She worked on stuff in the beginning, but it was really interesting. We were like, what? This is crazy. Like, I'm so familiar with this footage and she's so familiar with this, but it actually made a lot of sense. And especially having Claire, I think, really do a pass on some of the more sentimental stuff in the end, you know, like her sensibilities, like to really find some stuff there that maybe I didn't see. And for me to attack some of the more, you know, bachelor party male bonding stuff, you know, I think Greg was smart. Did you take anything from the set when we wrapped? So I have two things that I took.
带着格雷格一起的精修版（polish pass）负责前半部分，克莱尔负责后半部分。然后我们把它们组合起来，我们依然像——我最后还在处理一些东西，她还在处理开头的一些东西，但真的很有趣。我们当时都想，什么？这太疯狂了。我对这些素材这么熟悉，而她对那些那么熟悉，但它实际上非常合乎逻辑。特别是让克莱尔，我觉得，真正去对最后那些更具感伤色彩的内容进行了一次润色，你知道，凭借她的审美，去真正找出一些我可能没有发现的东西。而我去处理那些更偏向，你知道，单身派对男性情谊之类的内容，你知道，我觉得格雷格很聪明。杀青时，你从片场拿走什么东西了吗？我有两件我拿走的东西。
This is the Galactica that Dwight hung up. As I said, I'm a huge Galactica fan and I chose the original model when I got to, as the director of ARM, I got to choose which Galactica, which version of the Galactica we would use. And Rain signed it for me. He said, David, Galactica loves you, or Rainn Wilson Dwight. And so I have this Galactica. This is the one that Philip, Philip looks at the Galactica the same way I do. So I have that. And I have something, uh, I think you said, uh, that somebody took the sign from the lobby. I have the backup one. Oh, that is awesome. Oh my God, that's fantastic. Yeah. So this is, this is the backup one that would hang up. I guess sometimes, you know, if we did any kind of stunts or, you know, if we had
这个就是德怀特挂起来的“银河号”（Galactica）。正如我所说，我是个超级“银河号”迷，当我作为副导演（director of ARM）有机会选择时，我选择了最初的模型，作为我们要使用的“银河号”，究竟是哪一个版本的“银河号”。雷恩为我签了名。他说，大卫，“银河号”爱你，或者雷恩·威尔逊/德怀特。所以我拥有这个“银河号”。这个就是菲利普，菲利普看“银河号”的眼神和我一模一样。所以我留着这个。我还有一样东西，呃，我想你刚才说，呃，有人把大厅的标志牌拿走了。我有备份的那块。哦，太棒了。哦天哪，这太棒了！是的，所以这个，这是会挂起来的备用标志牌。我想有时候，你知道的，如果我们拍任何特技动作，或者，如果我们有
something that could potentially get the sign messy, or if we needed to do anything on the fly where we had to build the wall, um, that was the backup one. Fantastic. Listen, I can gush. I, I mean, I love you guys. I love you guys. I love the cast. I hope that was, I think that was known on the, on the set. I was just such a fan and I always, you know, wanted your best stuff to come out and to protect you guys and to make it look funny when, you know, when, whenever you guys did something to always show your, your best, not to make you look funny, but to always show your best funniest performances and also your most heartfelt. I mean, I just, and I loved anybody who came on the show. You know, I was, I was a fan of a, you know, when Rashida came on, when Ed Helms came on,
可能会弄脏标志牌的东西，或者如果我们需要即兴做任何需要砌墙的工作，呃，那块就是备用牌。太棒了。听着，我可以滔滔不绝。我，我的意思是，我爱你们。我爱你们大家。我爱演员们。我希望，我想这一点在片场是众所周知的。我真的是个超级粉丝，我总是，你知道，希望你们最棒的东西能展现出来，去保护你们，让它看起来很搞笑，当，你知道，每当你们做出什么举动时，总是能展现出你们的，最好的一面——不是为了让你们看起来滑稽可笑，而是为了始终展现你们最棒、最搞笑的表演，以及你们最真挚的表演。我的意思是，我只是，我喜欢任何来到这个剧组的人。你知道，我，我一直是个粉丝，你知道的，当拉什达（Rashida）来的时候，当艾德·海姆斯（Ed Helms）来的时候，
was Zach Woods. I mean, anybody, even the new, even the new guys, when they came on Clark and, you know, Jake, when they came on, you know, anybody who, who became a part of the family, I always just wanted their best stuff to come out and, and to let them know when they, you know, to reassure them, Hey, you guys are doing good work. You're doing good work. It's really funny. It's working. No, Dave, we loved you so much. Oh, Dave, thank you so much for coming today to talk to us. This was so great. Thanks, Dave. You have to come back. I would love to come back any time. All right, Dave. Bye, Dave. Bye, guys. All right, we are back. Thank you, Dave. Again, thank you. I mean, amazing. Amazing. And we can't wait for you to come back. I mean,
还有扎克·伍兹（Zach Woods）。我的意思是，任何人，甚至是新的，甚至是新人，当他们加入时，克拉克（Clark）和，你知道，杰克（Jake）加入时，你知道，任何成为这个大家庭一部分的人，我总是希望他们最棒的东西能展现出来，并且让他们知道，你知道，去安慰他们，嘿，你们干得好。你们干得好。这真的很好笑。这行得通。不，戴夫，我们太爱你啦。哦，戴夫，非常感谢你今天来和我们聊天。这太棒了。谢谢你，戴夫。你得常来。我随时都愿意再来。好的，戴夫。再见，戴夫。再见，各位。好的，我们回来了。谢谢你，戴夫。再次谢谢你。我的意思是，太棒了。太棒了。我们等不及你再来了。我的意思是，
I know we said that too, but we are going to hold you to it. Well, Angela, where should we begin? I know where you want to begin. I need to desperately begin with Clementine Paddleford. Yes, we called her Clementine Paddleford, but we have come to learn that her name is pronounced Clementine. Yes. And her close friends called her Clem. That was her nickname. But guys, I, I hate to tell you this is not all we've learned about her. We both listened to a podcast about her life. It's an amazing podcast, Jenna, called Fierce. Yeah, it tells the stories of forgotten women in history that changed the world. And Clementine Paddleford was their first episode. Yes, you can find it. I think it's on iHeart. Fierce. Fantastic podcast series. So we listened to
我知道我们也这么说过了，但我们一定会兑现承诺的。好吧，安吉拉，我们从哪儿开始呢？我知道你想从哪儿开始。我迫切需要从克莱门汀·帕德尔福德（Clementine Paddleford）开始。是的，我们管她叫克莱门汀·帕德尔福德，但我们后来得知她的名字读作克莱门汀（Clementine）。是的。而且她的密友都叫她克莱姆（Clem）。那是她的昵称。但是伙们，我，我讨厌告诉你们，这还不是我们关于她了解到的全部。我们俩都听了一期关于她生平的播客。詹娜，这是一个非常棒的播客，叫《Fierce》（译者注：意为凶猛、杰出女性）。是的，它讲述了历史上被遗忘的改变世界的女性的故事。而克莱门汀·帕德尔福德就是他们的第一期节目。是的，你们可以找到它。我想它在iHeart上。《Fierce》。非常棒的播客系列。所以我们听了
that. And then I read some fantastic articles about her. One of the ones I loved was by Linda Rodriguez McRobie and it's featured on mentalfloss.com. It is so good. I might have to do a swipe up to it in Insta story, Jenna. It's really great. Tell us what you learned, Angela. Oh, I don't even know where to start, Jenna. I don't even know where to start. I'm so excited to talk about this woman. First of all, when you think about every sort of food blogger or someone who writes about food in the world today, she was the first. She was the pioneer. Yes, because she talked about the process of making food, not just how the food tasted when she ate it, but she made it a point to go into the kitchens, to go into people's homes and watch how they cook. And then she wrote about
那个。然后我读了一些关于她的精彩文章。我最喜欢的一篇是琳达·罗德里格斯·麦克罗比（Linda Rodriguez McRobie）写的，发表在mentalfloss.com上。写得太好了。詹娜，我可能得在Ins快拍里给它做一个上滑链接（swipe up）。真的太棒了。安吉拉，告诉我们你学到了什么。哦，我都不知道从哪里开始，詹娜。我都不知道从哪里开始。我太兴奋能谈论这位女性了。首先，当你想到当今世界上的每一个美食品尝博主或任何写美食文章的人时，她就是第一人。她是先驱。是的，因为她探讨的是制作食物的过程，而不仅仅是食物吃起来的味道，她特意走进厨房，走进人们的家中，观察他们是如何烹饪的。然后她把这些写了下来，
this in this like beautiful, poetic storytelling kind of way that made it like just riveting. And it is 100% the basis of food writing today. Yes. If you think of someone like Anthony Bourdain, Clementine started that type of genre. And what I love about her too, Jenna, is that she never ever let anyone identify who she could be or how she could do it. She was born in Manhattan, Kansas. She ended up in Manhattan, New York. She never took no for an answer. She was traveling all over like writing about food. And she couldn't get to all the places she wanted too fast enough. So she learned how to fly a plane. Yes. She could fly herself around. I thought that was so badass. She went back to school when she was 50. She went on a nuclear
用这种美丽、诗意的叙事方式，让人读起来惊心动魄。这100%是现代美食写作的基础。是的。如果你想到像安东尼·波登（Anthony Bourdain）这样的人，克莱门汀就是那种流派的开创者。而且詹娜，我最喜欢她的一点是，她从来没有让任何人定义她可以成为什么样的人，或者她应该如何去做。她出生在堪萨斯州曼哈顿。最终她来到了纽约曼哈顿。她从不接受“不”字。她到处旅行，撰写关于美食的文章。而且她无法足够快地去到所有她想去的地方。于是她学会了开飞机。是的。她可以自己开飞机到处飞。我觉得这太酷、太飒了。她50岁时重返校园。61岁时，她登上了一艘核潜艇，去看看你是如何喂饱那么多水手的。不可思议。充满激情。伙计们，她是一位了不起的女性。顺便说一句，她，她对美耐华（Benihana）的报道正是美耐华爆火的原因。是的。这就是那家餐厅之所以成为现在这样的原因。伙计们，她写了一本书。她花了12年时间，将她所有的旅行经历和美食体验汇编在一起。这本书叫《美国人如何饮食》（How America Eats）。我找到一本。我丈夫给我买了一本，我马上要拿到了。我马上就能拿到了。天哪。太棒了。我太兴奋了。伙计们，谢谢你们容忍我在克莱门汀的话题上扯了这么远。但既然我们在《美耐华圣诞节》（Benihana Christmas）期间讨论过她，我们需要复盘一些我们漏掉的事情，詹娜。首先，
submarine to see how you feed that many sailors when she was 61 years old. Incredible. Such a passion. She's an incredible woman, you guys. And by the way, she, her article on Benihana is why Benihana blew up. Yes. It's why that restaurant became what it is. And you guys, she wrote a book. It took her 12 years to compile it all from all her travels and all her food experiences. It's called How America Eats. I found one. My husband bought it for me and I'm getting it. I'm getting it. My gosh. That's amazing. I'm so excited. You guys, thank you for indulging me on that whole Clementine tangent. But since we discussed her during Benihana Christmas, we need to go over a few things we miss Jenna. First off,
迈克尔骑着自行车出场时，克里斯蒂·G（Christie G）、劳伦·S（Lauren S）、科林·C（Colin C）、索菲亚·M（Sophia M）、贾斯汀·L（Justin L）以及其他许许多多的人都想知道，在冷开场（cold open）中，迈克尔在骑自行车。然而，在未来的某集里，有一个冷开场，我们得知迈克尔从来没学会怎么骑自行车。这是一个连续性错误（continuity error）吗？剧本圣经（show Bible）里有没有提到迈克尔骑自行车的技能？嗯，安吉拉，我去剧本圣经里查了这件事。但你猜怎么着？什么？我的剧本圣经只写到了第六季。哦，不，我不知道这个。我在翻。而且我有一本不完整的剧本圣经。我为自己偷到一本不完整的剧本圣经感到太失望了。所以怎么办？我们得去找格雷格。我做了一点挖掘。好的。这是真的。
when Michael enters riding the bike, Christie G, Lauren S, Colin C, Sophia M, Justin L, and many, many more wanted to know in the cold open, Michael is riding a bike. However, in a future episode, there is a cold open where we learn that Michael never learned how to ride a bike. Is this a continuity error? Does the show Bible say anything about Michael's bike riding abilities? Well, Angela, I went to look this up in the show Bible. But guess what? What? My show Bible only goes through season six. Oh, no, I didn't know this. I'm flipping. And I have an incomplete show Bible. I'm so disappointed in myself for stealing an incomplete show Bible. So what? We got to hit up Greg. I did a little digging. Okay. And it's true.
在第七季第五集《复仇记》（The Sting）中，迈克尔说他不会骑自行车。我觉得这只是个失误。这是一个连续性错误，但它确实是个错误。这个发现也是ScreenRant网站上一篇名为《办公室里只有真爱粉才注意到的25个错误》的文章的一部分。我们讨论过其中的一些，比如他们谈到的其他错误之一是，到底是谁最先入职邓德米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）？是吉姆还是帕姆，或者是帕姆的妈妈换人了这件事。它还提到了我们在《美耐华》中讨论过的内容，安吉拉，关于你姐妹的事——你到底有几个姐妹？对吧。所有类似的事情。基本上，伙计们，我只想说，好眼力。是的。好吧，接下来还会有一些事情。我最喜欢的一个细节（我们稍后会讲到），就是
In season seven, episode five, The Sting, Michael says he can't ride a bike. I think this was just a mistake. It is a continuity error, but it is an error. This catch is also part of an article on ScreenRant called 25 Mistakes in the Office that Only True Fans Noticed. We have discussed some of them, like some of the other ones they talk about is who really started at Dunder Mifflin first? Was it Jim or Pam or the fact that Pam's mom changes? It also mentions what we did talk about in Benny Hanna, Angela, the thing about your sisters, like how many sisters do you really have? Right. All that kind of stuff. Basically, guys, I just have to say good catch. Yeah. Well, there's going to be a few things. One of my favorites, which we'll get to, is that
参议员有一个儿子。当我遇到他时，他有一个儿子，而我们再也没有见过那个孩子。怎么回事？是的。真是在草堆里白忙活。好吧，我们还忘了提《美耐华圣诞节》里关于浴袍的整个桥段。还记得在这集里，总公司（Corporate）给每个人发了一件浴袍。但托比（Toby）没有。迈克尔把它拿走了。所以托比花了一整集时间都在渴望有一件浴袍。最后，帕姆给了他一件。但是安吉拉，很多人来信想了解更多关于这些浴袍的事。例如，每个人都想知道我们在现实生活中是否也拿到了一件。我们没有拿到那件浴袍。那件浴袍是个道具。不过，有一年我们确实收到了制作人送的礼物——一件浴袍，詹娜。
the senator has a son. When I meet him, he has a son, and we never see that kid again. What happened? Yeah. That's right. Out in the hay. Well, we also forgot to mention the whole runner with the bath robes in Benny Hanna Christmas. Remember, in this episode, Corporate gives everybody a bathrobe. But Toby doesn't get one. Michael takes it away. So Toby spends the whole episode sort of pining away for a bathrobe. Finally, in the end, Pam gives him one. But Angela, a lot of people wrote in and wanted to know more about these robes. For example, everyone wanted to know if we got one in real life. We did not get that robe. That robe was a prop. We did, however, get a gift from our producers one year of a bathrobe, Jenna.
是的，就像一件蓝色的毛巾布浴袍，上面印着“The Office”。我到现在还在穿。我的狗把袖子咬了个洞，但我舍不得扔。我还在穿。它太舒服了。我也有我的那件。穿上它感觉就像真的裹着一条毯子。嗯，这个情节里我最喜欢的场景之一，就是托比在厨房和凯文说话的那场戏，他那种，他那种简直就像充满渴望地抚摸着凯文的浴袍，恨不得自己也有一件的样子。是的，完全如此。好吧，我们在《美耐华圣诞节》里收到了布鲁克·比格尔（Brooke Beagle）的一个粉丝捕捉点：在14分32秒时，你可以在凯文身后看到一张《Happening's》杂志的海报。那是斯克兰顿当地真正的杂志吗？是的。《Happening's》杂志创办于1969年，其宗旨是鼓励人们在斯克兰顿和威尔克斯-巴里（Wilkes-Barre）之间旅游，参加不同的文化活动。到了2004年，他们甚至创建了网络版。伙计们，纸质版和网络版现在都存在。你们今天可以在 happeningsmagazinepa.com 上找到它们。看吧，现在，我会很喜欢这个。我会去看看那里发生了什么。你知道，也许那里有什么南瓜园，或者有摘苹果活动，或者你根本不知道。你永远不知道发生了什么。我喜欢当地的社区简报。我订阅了我镇上的本地简报。我祖母曾为报纸写过一个专栏，名叫《镇里镇外》（Around the Town）。里面全都是镇上发生的一些琐事。就只是周围发生的事情，你知道的，就发生在镇上。听起来非常类似于《Happening's》杂志。
Yes, like a blue terry cloth bathrobe that said the office on it. I still wear it. My dog ate a hole in the sleeve, but I won't give it up. I still wear it. It's so cozy. I still have mine too. It's like really wearing a blanket. Well, one of my favorite scenes from this plotline is the scene where Toby is in the kitchen and he's talking to Kevin and he's sort of he's sort of just like stroking Kevin's robe like longingly wishing he had one. Yes, exactly. Well, we had a fan catch from Brooke Beagle in Benny Hanna Christmas at 14 minutes 32 seconds. You can see a poster for Happening's magazine right behind Kevin. Is that a real local Scranton magazine? Yes. Happening's magazine was founded in 1969 and its purpose was to encourage people to travel
是的。我祖母可能会很喜欢《Happening's》杂志。好吧，詹娜，我想讨论几个被删减的场景，我认为这些场景确实为我们提供了一些关于某些角色的有趣信息。哦，说吧。你知道我喜欢克里德。所以我先从克里德开始。所以在《罪犯》（The Convict）中，有一个被删减的单人访谈（talking head），克里德在其中说他曾进过监狱。事实上，他就是在那儿得到了他的名字。克里德进过监狱。这意味着克里德不是他的本名。这只是他在监狱里得到的名字。他没有深入展开。我们不知道原因。接着他说他过去常常在马桶里酿造一种叫做普鲁诺（pruno）的酒。那种酒是用水果、糖和番茄酱做的。
between Scranton and Wilkes-Berry for different cultural events. And in 2004, they even created an online version. Guys, both the print version and online version exist today. You can find them today at happeningsmagazinepa.com. See now, I would love that. I would check that out to see what was happening. You know, maybe there's like a pumpkin patch or there's apple picking or you don't know. You don't know what's happening. I love local newsletters. I subscribe to my town's local newsletter. My grandmother wrote a column for the newspaper called Around the Town. It was just stuff happening around the town. It was just what was happening, you know, around the town. Yeah. Sounds very similar to Happening's magazine.
而且他真的，真的很怀念那种酒。天哪。普鲁诺酒。你一说番茄酱，我的胃就直翻腾。太恶心了。我的意思是，从马桶开始，然后当你说到番茄酱时，简直形成了一个完美的闭环。克里德酿造普鲁诺酒。嗯，这很有趣，因为这与《酒水巡游》（Booze Cruise）中被删减的那个单人访谈相矛盾。在那个访谈中，克里德承认自己就是他自己——来自草根乐队（the Grassroots）的克里德·布拉顿。但这两个单人访谈都被删掉了。所以我想这也没关系。我觉得对于克里德来说，一切都无所谓。百无禁忌。他住在办公桌底下。
Yes. My grandmother probably would have loved Happening's magazine. Okay. Well, Jenna, I would like to discuss a few deleted scenes that I think really give us some fun information about some characters. Oh, go. You know, I love Creed. So I'm going to start with Creed. So in the convict, there is a deleted talking head where Creed says that he's been to prison. And in fact, that's where he got his name. Creed was in prison. Meaning that like Creed is not his given name. It's just the name he got in prison. He doesn't go into it. We don't know why. And then he goes on to say that he used to make a type of wine called pruno in the toilets. And it's made of fruit, sugar, and ketchup.
他住在多伦多。我们不知道他住哪儿。他有多个名字、多重身份。你知道克里德最棒的地方是什么吗？从编剧的角度来看，那就是无所谓。是的。因为你永远不知道克里德说的是真是假。为他写剧本可太有意思了。所以另一个被删减的场景，太棒了，詹娜，你知道，詹娜，你一直在说你对瑞恩这个角色有了新的欣赏。是的。好吧，对我来说，是菲利斯。我怎么也看不够她。
And he really, he really misses that wine. Oh my God. Pruno. That actually made my stomach turn when you said ketchup. It's so disgusting. I mean, it started with toilet. And then it went full circle when you said ketchup. Creed making pruno. Well, this is interesting because that would be at odds with the booze crews deleted talking head in which Creed admits to being himself, Creed Bratton from the grassroots. But both of those talking heads were deleted. So I guess it doesn't matter. I think with Creed, nothing matters. All bets are off. He lives under a desk.
所以在《罪犯》中，帕姆和菲利斯之间有一个被删减的片段。迈克尔把所有人都锁在会议室里。在被删减的场景中，有一段真正的时间流逝，这在正片里并没有发生。我想我们在仅有的21分30秒的时长里，确实没有足够的时间，你知道的。就像戴夫刚才说的那样。是的，所以他们不得不大幅度删减。但这里有一个非常棒的场景，菲利斯正在向帕姆展示她的订婚戒指，詹娜，那不是一个小碎钻簇（cluster）。
He lives in Toronto. We don't know where he lives. He's got multiple names, identities. And you know what's great about Creed, I think from the writer's standpoint, is that it didn't matter. Yes. Because you never know if Creed's telling the truth or not. It's such a fun character to write for. So the other deleted scene, which is so good, Jenna, you know, Jenna, you keep saying you have a new appreciation for the character of Ryan. Yes. Well, for me, it's Phyllis. I can't get enough of her.
不是小碎钻簇？我们早就知道了。我们猜中了。不是小碎钻簇。那是一枚巨大的马眼形（marquee）订婚戒指，巨大的马眼形钻石。事实上，她还向帕姆炫耀。她说，你知道，这是最贵的钻石类型。而且鲍勃（Bob）本来想给我买一颗更大的呢。这在最开始的那场戏中就说得通了——当时她告诉迈克尔她订婚了。
So there is this deleted moment between Pam and Phyllis and the convict. Michael has locked everyone in the conference room. And in the deleted scenes, there's a real passage of time that doesn't happen in the episode. I guess we just didn't have enough time, you know, in the 21 minutes and 30 seconds that we get. Like what Dave was saying. Yeah. So they have to really truncate it. But there's this great scene where Phyllis is showing Pam her engagement ring. And Jenna, it's not a cluster.
她手指上戴着那个小碎钻簇。他们当时还没有拿到她的戒指呢。那显然是。而且这就说得通了，她当然会从来自Vance制冷公司的鲍勃·万斯（Bob Vance）那里得到一颗硕大的钻石。哦。哦，我真希望他们能把这个保留在正片里。是的，真的很有趣。非常可爱。她对此感到无比、无比骄傲。好吧，那么，安吉拉，现在人们对我们有点意见了。
It's not a cluster? We knew it. We called it. It's not a cluster. It is an enormous marquee engagement ring, huge marquee diamond. And in fact, she brags to Pam. She's like, you know, this is the most expensive type of diamond. And Bob wanted to get me even a bigger one. This makes so much more sense in that very first scene when she tells Michael that she's engaged.
这不是碎钻镶嵌？我们早就知道了。我们猜对了。这不是碎钻。这是一枚巨大的马眼形订婚戒指，是一颗巨大的马眼形钻石。事实上，她向潘炫耀。她说，你知道的，这是最昂贵的钻石类型。鲍勃本来想给我买一个更大的。这样一来，在第一场她告诉迈克尔她订婚了的那场戏里，一切就都说得通了。
She had that little cluster on her finger. They did not have her ring yet. That is that is clearly. And it makes sense that she would have a big old diamond from Bob Vance, a Vance refrigeration. Yes. Oh. Oh, I wish they'd kept that in. Yeah. And it's really fun. It's really cute. She's so, so proud of it. All right. Well, Angela, now people have a gripe with us.
她手指上戴着那个小碎钻。他们当时还没拿到她的戒指。这显然是这样的。而且，她戴着来自“寒冷与制冷”的鲍勃·万斯送的大钻戒，这就说得通了。是的。哦。哦，我真希望他们能保留那个情节。是的。这真的很有趣。真的很可爱。她为之感到无比、无比的自豪。好吧，安吉拉，现在人们对我们有意见了。
What do we do? It's about our assessment of Wishiwashi, Jim. Oh, well, I thought that might be coming. Crystal Nichols wrote in to say, I don't think Jim is Wishiwashi, nor does he opam an explanation about Karen. Amy Durham agrees. Pam flirted with Jim and established intimacy with him for seasons one through three,
我们该怎么做？吉姆，这是关于我们对“摇摆不定”的吉姆的评价。哦，好吧，我猜这可能会来。克里斯塔·尼科尔斯（Crystal Nichols）写信说，我认为吉姆不是摇摆不定的，他对凯伦也没有什么好解释的。艾米·达勒姆（Amy Durham）表示赞同。从第一季到第三季，潘一直在调戏吉姆，并与他建立了亲密关系，
but then always went home to Roy. Oh, well, that's there's some truth there. Bronte thinks that there are times when Jim is downright mean or disrespectful and doesn't think that he should always be called a nice guy. But Emily Hubbard defends Jim by saying he is making an effort to be friends with Pam while not crossing the line into flirtation. He likewise doesn't lay it on thick with Karen in front of Pam out of respect. But since Pam kept Jim on the hook for so long,
但随后总是回家找罗伊。哦，好吧，这其中确实有些道理。布朗蒂（Bronte）认为，有时吉姆简直是刻薄或无礼，她认为不应该总是称他为好人。但埃米莉·哈伯德（Emily Hubbard）为吉姆辩护说，他在努力与潘做朋友，同时没有越过调情的界限。出于尊重，他在潘面前也没有和凯伦过于亲密。但由于潘吊了吉姆这么久，
he's right not to do the same thing to Pam in return. I think it's just people are pointing out Pam started the Wishiwashi. Pam, her Wishiwashi-ness to me was like another level because she was engaged in living with someone. And I know her heart was like falling for Jim, and she was having sort of almost like this emotional affair. But she was 100% having an emotional affair. Yeah, exactly.
他反过来不对潘这样做是正确的。我认为这只是人们在指出是潘先开始摇摆不定的。潘，在我看来，她的摇摆不定达到了另一个层面，因为她已经订婚并与某人同居了。我知道她的内心像是爱上了吉姆，她几乎是在进行这种精神出轨。但她百分之百就是在精神出轨。是的，完全正确。
And then also trying to figure out like, well, I've put so much time in with Roy. So she was definitely doing all this waffling. And then I don't know, it's really hard. This is the Star Cross Lovers story. Well, we have a final thought from Randall Robertson who wrote this. I'm coming to the defense of Jim being Wishiwashi. Don't you ladies remember young love?
然后还在琢磨，嗯，我和罗伊在一起花了那么多时间。所以她确实在左右摇摆。然后，我不知道，这真的很难。这是一个苦命鸳鸯的故事。好吧，我们有兰德尔·罗伯逊（Randall Robertson）的最后想法，他写道：我来为吉姆并非摇摆不定进行辩护。女士们，你们不记得年轻时的爱情了吗？
Pam was Jim's everything. He told her he loved her and then kissed her and she kissed him back. She then told him she was going to still marry Roy. Pam tore Jim's heart into a million pieces, then put those pieces in a shredder behind her desk. Karen is a rebound. And now he has to be in the same space as the woman who put him in his heartbroken state.
潘就是吉姆的一切。他告诉她他爱她，然后吻了她，她也吻了他。然后她告诉他她还是要嫁给罗伊。潘把吉姆的心撕成了成百万个碎片，然后把这些碎片塞进她办公桌后面的碎纸机里。凯伦只是个替代品。现在他不得不和那个让他心碎的女人呆在同一个空间里。
When you have no heart to give anyone, all you get is Wishiwashi. Randall Robertson, that was amazing. And it's true, we were too hard on Jim. Randall, that last line, when you have no heart to give anyone, all you get is Wishiwashi. Yeah.
当你心里没有什么可以给任何人时，你得到的只有摇摆不定。兰德尔·罗伯逊，这太棒了。而且确实如此，我们对吉姆太苛刻了。兰德尔，最后那句，当你心里没有什么可以给任何人时，你得到的只有摇摆不定。是的。
Well, there was a little bit of debate, Jenna, about whether or not Toby outed Oscar or if he had Oscar's permission to disclose he was gay in the Gay Witch Hunt episode. We were giving Toby a lot of grief about this, remember? Yes. Emily Zaloum says 100% Oscar outed Oscar, to which Caitlin Workman and Annie Day both point out,
詹娜，关于托比是出卖了奥斯卡，还是在《同性恋女巫大搜捕》那一集里得到了奥斯卡的允许才透露他是同性恋，有一点小小的争论。我们当时为这件事没少数落托比，还记得吗？是的。埃米莉·扎卢姆（Emily Zaloum）说奥斯卡100%是自己出柜的，对此凯特琳·沃克曼（Caitlin Workman）和安妮·戴（Annie Day）都指出，
at the end of Toby and Michael's conversation, Toby says Oscar obviously hopes he can count on your discretion, which they think sort of implies that Oscar gave Toby permission to tell Michael. So Toby saying Oscar hopes he can count on you. To be discreet. Means, I guess, that maybe filling in the blanks, Toby said to Oscar,
在托比和迈克尔对话的最后，托比说奥斯卡显然希望他能指望你的谨慎，他们认为这某种程度上暗示了奥斯卡允许托比告诉迈克尔。所以托比说奥斯卡希望他能指望你保持谨慎。我的意思是，这可能意味着，脑补一下，托比对奥斯卡说，
do you mind if I share this information with Michael, to which Oscar said, yes, but please ask him I would appreciate his discretion. I don't buy it. I don't think Oscar would trust Michael with anything about his personal life. You know what, even more, I think Toby has to be like, okay, let's say I do have Oscar's permission.
你介意我把这个信息分享给迈克尔吗？对此奥斯卡说，可以，但请告诉他我很感激他的谨慎。我不买账。我认为奥斯卡不会把任何关于他个人生活的事托付给迈克尔。你知道吗，更何况，我觉得托比当时肯定在想，好吧，假设我得到了奥斯卡的允许，
Is this still the conversation I should have with Michael? I mean, he kind of has to have the conversation, right? Because he has to speak to Michael about his behavior. Well, gosh, now I think they're, now I think they're right. Oh my goodness. The more you're talking, now I'm like, oh, oh yeah, Toby had to say something and Oscar was like, okay, well, if you tell him, it's okay.
这依然是我该和迈克尔进行的对话吗？我的意思是，他某种程度上必须进行这个对话，对吧？因为他必须就迈克尔的行为跟他谈谈。哦，天哪，现在我觉得他们，现在我觉得他们是对的。哦，我的天哪。你越说，现在我就觉得，哦，哦，是的，托比必须说点什么，而奥斯卡则像是，好吧，如果你告诉他，那没关系。
Guys, I see it, I see it. Well, listen, I wanted to throw out a couple of tidbits that people sent in that I found really fun and interesting. These are both references to the convention episode. So first off, Joe Cerbera told us, the president of the University of Scranton used ain't no party like a Scranton party in his commencement addresses,
伙计们，我明白了，我明白了。好吧，听着，我想抛出几个大家发来的趣闻轶事，我觉得非常有趣。这些都是对《会议》那一集的引用。首先，乔·塞尔贝拉（Joe Cerbera）告诉我们，斯克兰顿大学的校长在他的毕业典礼演讲中使用了“没有什么聚会能比得上斯克兰顿聚会”，
and that it has become the unofficial motto of the University of Scranton. And of course, the convention is the episode where we first hear that. That's fantastic. Okay, so second, you remember the scene where Michael meets Jerome Bettis, the football player, and he thinks that he has the nickname the bus
并且这已经成为了斯克兰顿大学的非官方座右铭。当然，《会议》那一集就是我们第一次听到这句话的地方。太棒了。好的，其次，还记得迈克尔遇到美式足球运动员杰罗姆·贝蒂斯（Jerome Bettis）的那场戏吗，他以为他有“公交车”这个绰号，
because he always traveled by bus and he's afraid to fly. Right. But of course, the reason he has that nickname is because people would pile on top of him and he would just keep moving. Right. He could carry a bunch of people. Right.
因为他总是坐公交车出行，而且他害怕坐飞机。对的。但当然，他有这个绰号的原因是人们会压在他身上，而他会继续前行。对的。他能驮着一群人。对的。
On the football field. Yes. Yes, exactly. So a bunch of people wrote in, Carly Mitchell, Kyle Gensler, and Paul Marshall all said, Michael got his NFL members mixed up. John Madden was known for being afraid to fly and only took the bus to games,
在橄榄球场上。是的。是的，完全正确。所以很多人写信来，卡莉·米切尔（Carly Mitchell）、凯尔·根斯勒（Kyle Gensler）和保罗·马歇尔（Paul Marshall）都说，迈克尔把他的NFL成员搞混了。约翰·马登（John Madden）以害怕坐飞机而闻名，只坐公交车去参加比赛，
but did not have the nickname the bus. But that is a true thing about John Madden. Oh, I didn't know that. Okay, so I looked this up and I found an article from the LA Times. It's from July of 1988. Okay. But this is what it says.
但并没有“公交车”这个绰号。但这关于约翰·马登是确有其事。哦，我不知道这件事。好吧，所以我查了一下，我找到了《洛杉矶时报》的一篇文章。那是1988年7月的。好吧。但上面是这样写的。
It says, there are 3,750 buses in the Greyhound Line Trailways fleet, but only one is famous. That one is called the Madden Cruiser. It is the vehicle in which John Madden, one of the nation's best known football analysts and broadcasters, rides around the country from game to game. It says that he's no longer willing to fly
它说，灰狗巴士和特雷威斯车队的车队中有3750辆公交车，但只有一辆是出名的。那一辆被称为马登巡洋舰。这就是全国最知名的橄榄球分析师和广播员之一约翰·马登乘坐它从一场比赛到另一场比赛穿梭于全国各地的交通工具。上面说他不再愿意坐飞机，
because he suffers from claustrophobia and he has not boarded a plane since 1979. Wow, I wonder if that's still the case. I don't know. It said he used to travel by train, but he had more freedom traveling by bus. So, yeah. So this is classic Michael,
因为他患有幽闭恐惧症，自1979年以来他就没有登上过飞机。哇，不知道现在还是这样吗。我不知道。上面说他曾经坐火车出行，但他坐公交车出行有更多的自由。所以，是的。所以这是典型的迈克尔，
where he had one part, one sort of like story from one football player mixing with another one. Yes, exactly. Well, here's something crazy, Angela. I don't know how he gets around today, but this bus was on display at the Pro Football Hall of Fame as recently as 2018, like you could tour it.
他把一个橄榄球运动员的一部门、一种故事和另一个混淆了。是的，完全正确。好吧，这里有一件疯狂的事，安吉拉。我不知道他今天是怎么出行的，但直到2018年，这辆公交车还在职业橄榄球名人堂展出，就像你可以去参观一样。
This is like the Lisa Marie plane at Graceland. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I've been to Graceland. I have too. Yeah. Well, I didn't go inside. I just saw it from outside.
这就像雅园的丽莎·玛丽号飞机一样。哦，是的。是的。我去过雅园。我也去过。是的。嗯，我没进去。我只是在外面看了看。
Oh, we went inside. Well, there was a really long line. Were you thinking there wouldn't be? Jenna, I was in my 20s. I was driving cross-country. I was like, oh, my God, wait, Elvis Presley lives near here. Let's go see. Oh, yeah.
哦，我们进去了。好吧，队排得很长。你以为不会吗？詹娜，我当时二十几岁。我正开车进行跨国旅行。我就想，哦，天哪，等一下，埃尔维斯·普雷斯利就住在附近。我们去看看吧。哦，是的。
This was when I was a kid. My mom would find all these vacations for us to go on that were in driving distance of St. Louis. So one year we drove to Memphis and we toured all kinds of stuff. I remember we went to a museum and we saw this very interesting exhibit on King Tut. And then the other thing we did was we toured Graceland. So we planned it all out.
这是我小时候的事。我妈妈会为我们找所有我们可以开车去度假的地方，都在圣路易斯的车程范围内。所以有一年我们开车去了孟菲斯，我们参观了各种各样的东西。我记得我们去了一个博物馆，我们看到了一个非常有趣的关于图坦卡蒙的展览。然后我们做的另一件事就是参观雅园。所以我们把一切都计划好了。
Well, I was driving with a girlfriend of mine because we were driving cross-country and she was moving. And we pulled in. There was a huge line, but in the parking lot was the plane. So I saw the plane, but I haven't been inside Graceland. Oh, in your 20s, when you plan nothing, you guys. All right. Yeah, exactly.
嗯，我当时和一个女友一起开车，因为我们在进行跨国旅行，她要搬家。我们把车开了进去。排着长队，但在停车场里停着那架飞机。所以我看到了飞机，但我没有进去过雅园。哦，在你们二十多岁的时候，什么都不计划，天哪。好吧。是的，完全正确。
Well, Jenna, I saw that we got a lot of mail about grief counseling and our bird tragedies we talked about. Yes. So many people witnessed terrible bird tragedies the same week as our podcast. I know. It was kind of wild, wasn't it? Yes.
好吧，詹娜，我看到我们收到了很多关于哀悼辅导以及我们谈论的鸟类悲剧的邮件。是的。就在我们播客播出的同一周，有那么多人目睹了可怕的鸟类悲剧。我知道。这有点疯狂，对吧？是的。
It was pretty wild. So this one really got me. Kayla Lawless wrote in and said she hit a bird with her car while listening to the podcast for grief counseling. Oh, my God. That's the first time she's ever hit a bird in her life. And she was listening to us talk about a bird funeral, and then she hit a bird.
这相当疯狂。所以这个真的让我惊到了。凯拉·劳利斯（Kayla Lawless）写信说，她在听关于哀悼辅导的播客时，开车撞到了一只鸟。哦，天哪。这是她生平第一次撞到鸟。当时她正在听我们谈论鸟类葬礼，然后她就撞到了一只鸟。
Oh, my God. I don't know how to feel about that. Kayla, I'm so sorry. You know what's weird? I am not seeing any more bird deaths. Are you? No, it's like it's too hot. And they're just like, ugh.
哦，天哪。我不知道该对此作何感想。凯拉，我太遗憾了。你知道有什么奇怪的吗？我没有看到更多的鸟类死亡了。你呢？没有，就好像天气太热了。它们就像，呃。
Yeah, my problem now is mosquitoes. Jenna, I got eaten up the other night. Like the kids and I are sitting and like comparing notes. Like, oh, I have four on this leg. Oh, I have two over here. I got this amazing candle that's like all natural. Are you going to get me one? Are you going to get your BFF one?
是的，我现在的问题是蚊子。詹娜，前几天晚上我被咬惨了。就像孩子们和我坐在一起对账一样。哦，我这条腿上有四个。哦，我这边有两个。我买了这个神奇的蜡烛，它是纯天然的。你要给我买一个吗？你要给你的挚友买一个吗？
Does it keep the mosquitoes away? Yes. And it's in a little bucket with a handle. So like, you know, because you move around outside, so I just move it with us and keep it nearby, and it seems to be working. Okay, I want one. All right, I'll send you one.
它能赶走蚊子吗？是的。它装在一个带提手的桶里。所以，你知道的，因为你在外面走动，所以我只是把它和我们一起移动，放在附近，它似乎很管用。好吧，我想要一个。好吧，我给你寄一个。
My friends growing up, my Aussie friends growing up, would always say, oh, the Aussies are out. So many Aussies. The Aussies. They sound authentic. Were you like, wait a second, Jenna, are you from Australia? Yeah, holy crap. Yeah, the Aussies are out.
我从小到大的朋友，我从小到大的澳大利亚朋友，总是说，哦，澳大利亚人出动了。好多澳大利亚人。澳大利亚人。他们听起来很地道。你当时是不是想，等一下，詹娜，你是从澳大利亚来的吗？是的，天哪。是的，澳大利亚人出动了。
Oh, the Aussies. Well, before we go, you guys, I want you to know that since my BFF, Jenna, did not know what Frisbee golf was, otherwise known as frulf. Would you like to go frothing? Yeah, guess what I've decided to do? I am going to have an office ladies Frisbee. Oh, no.
哦，澳大利亚人。好吧，在我们离开之前，伙计们，我想让你们知道，既然我的挚友詹娜不知道什么是飞盘高尔夫，也就是俗称的“frulf”。你想去玩“frulf”吗？是的，猜猜我决定做什么？我要举办一个办公室女士飞盘活动。哦，不。
Yeah, and you know, because I love to chunk it. I'm going to have them put chunk it on it. What? This is a double trolling. It's double trolling. It's a chunk it Frisbee. And then we've got to go frothing. Okay, we can socially distance frulf, lady.
是的，你知道的，因为我喜欢扔它。我要让他们在上面印上“扔它”。什么？这是双重钓鱼执法。这是双重钓鱼执法。这是一个“扔它”飞盘。然后我们得去玩“frulf”。好吧，我们可以保持社交距离来玩飞盘，女士。
We can. And I would love to. We have a lot of assignments. We have to drink rosé and watch LaCouche talking. Yes. We have to go on a boat at some point and we have to frulf. We have to frulf with our chunk it office ladies Frisbee. Okay, I like it.
我们可以。我很乐意。我们有很多任务。我们必须喝桃红葡萄酒并看劳切说话。是的。我们在某个时候必须坐船，我们必须玩飞盘。我们必须带着我们的“扔它”办公室女士飞盘去玩“frulf”。好吧，我喜欢。
How can you do that? But you can't like even attempt an Australian accent. Well, I don't know what she's saying. She's talking about some kind of obby lobbies. How do you say mosquito again? On mazzies. Mubble lobbies. How about that?
你怎么能那样做？但你甚至不能尝试模仿澳大利亚口音。好吧，我不知道她在说什么。她在谈论某种大堂大堂。你刚才怎么说蚊子的？On mazzies。Mubble lobbies。这个怎么样？
How about a mubble? Well, thank you guys for sending in all your questions. We had a really fun time going through those. We hope you like the episode today. And thank you so much to Dave Rogers. That was such a fun interview. And we will keep posting your heartbreaks in the break room. Look for them over on office ladies pod on Instagram.
Mubble怎么样？好吧，谢谢你们发来你们所有的问题。我们回顾这些度过了一段非常有趣的时光。我们希望你们喜欢今天的节目。非常感谢戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）。那是一次非常有趣的采访。我们会继续把你们的心碎故事发在休息室里。请在Instagram上的 office ladies pod 上寻找它们。
Yes, you guys, we're going to try to post more because you're also sending in really fun fan art and all kinds of things. So we're going to step it up. Yes, we will step it up. And next week is. Business school. Okay, Pam's art show.
是的，伙计们，我们要尝试发布更多内容，因为你们也发来了非常有趣的粉丝艺术和各种各样的东西。所以我们要加大力度。是的，我们会加把劲的。下周是。商学院。好吧，潘的艺术展。
Pam's art show. Talk about a heartbreaker. Well, as we leave you today, I really want to play this song. You know, I love bluegrass. Yes. This is a bluegrass version of heartbreak in the break room from Jay Zaire from Harrisonburg, Virginia. Thank you, Jay.
潘的艺术展。说起让人心碎的事。好吧，在我们今天离开之际，我真的很想放这首歌。你知道的，我喜欢蓝草音乐。是的。这是来自弗吉尼亚州哈里森堡的杰·扎伊尔（Jay Zaire）带来的蓝草音乐版本的休息室心碎。谢谢你，杰。
See you guys next week. See you next week. Okay, kids, suspend your disbelief and pretend this is being sung by the vivacious Jenna Fisher. Or as the Amish say, Ms. Jopinavi Fabishavard. Mama's sexy sweater can't make my man love me. He found a hussy on the slow train from Philadelphia. I'm feeling mighty hunchy, just like Creed on LSD.
大家下周见。下周见。好了，孩子们，收起你们的不信任，假装这是由活力四射的詹娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）唱的。或者用阿米什人的话说，Jopinavi Fabishavard女士。妈妈性感的毛衣无法让我的男人爱我。他在开往费城的慢车上找到了一个水性杨花的女人。我感到非常多疑，就像吸了LSD的克里德一样。
Heartbreak in the break room, my Dunder Mifflin destiny. Heartbreak in the break room, a pimple everyone can see. I'll drown my sorrows in mixed berry yogurt, and it's all gonna be on TV. I wish that that would please come back and end my misery. Heartbreak in the break room, it's as hard as hard can be. That's what she said. Heartbreak in the break room, heartbreak in the break room. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
休息室里的心碎，我邓德米夫林的命运。休息室里的心碎，每个人都能看到的青春痘。我要把悲伤淹没在混合浆果酸奶中，这一切都将在电视上播出。我希望那能回来结束我的痛苦。休息室里的心碎，它有多难就有多难。这就是她说的。休息室里的心碎，休息室里的心碎。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is produced by Irwin, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由欧文（Irwin）、詹娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kieffer）。我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布巴科夫（Ainsley Bubakow）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡胶树》。有关《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。有关 Stitcher Premium 的一个月免费试用，请使用代码 OFFICE。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。